first we should ask the question whether
large language models have achieved
anything anything in this domain answer
no they've achieved zero
[Music]
hello street talkers welcome back to the
channel today is a special episode for
me personally an emotional episode we've
been through quite a tumultuous journey
to to create this episode for reasons
which will become abundantly clear
pretty soon but noam chomsky is an
intellectual heavyweight he's one of my
personal heroes and it truly is a dream
come true for us to have this experience
of interviewing him so anyway i really
hope you enjoy the show today we are
coming live from lake como in italy i
think this is possibly one of the most
beautiful places on planet earth and
you know in a douglas hofstadter style i
hope that adds a little bit of flavor to
the creativity behind this episode
anyway enjoy
thank you so much to our patreons i
wanted to give a special shout out
actually to our vip patreons alex
mcnamara and ebonia elliot lewis
now um psychologically if nothing else
it helps us so much having your support
and we're also interested in finding
sponsors for the show and of course
don't forget to join our amazing discord
community but um no we we really
appreciate our community and our support
and thank you so much welcome back to
street talk today is absolutely
incredible our dream came true and we
got to interview our hero professor noam
chomsky
walid couldn't even keep his [ __ ]
together he had a jizz face for pretty
much the entire interview chomsky is an
intellectual heavyweight he's probably
the most important intellectual of the
20th century uh he's been cited so many
times i mean we're quite spoilt here on
mlst because fristen and bengio also are
in the top 100 of scientists based on
their h score but it was an incredible
honor to speak with chomsky to me i
still have 10 chomsky books on my
bookshelf downstairs i went through a
certain political phase at university
and uh no harm in that i think it was
very enriching for me going forwards in
my life but yeah he's been a towering
figure i think in so many people's lives
throughout the entire 20th century and
beyond
this is going to be a long show it's
going to be over three and a half hours
long so use the table of contents to
skip around this first chapter is mostly
about yan lacoon and the reason we
wanted to talk about him and his recent
paper is because as a radical empiricist
he's the antithesis of chomsky and i
think it frames some of the subsequent
discussion nicely but if you want to
skip ahead and you know just only do
chomsky stuff then it's about 50 minutes
to skip look at the table of contents so
chapter one really the revolution that
has happened over the last decades is
the fact that we've realized that ai has
to be
intimately linked with learning
uh the fact that when we observe uh
you know any animal with a brain in
nature is capable of learning
um and perhaps because i'm
i'm lazy or because i don't think i'm
very smart i i i've always thought that
it would be very difficult to just
uh design uh from scratch uh an
intelligent system an intelligent system
has to basically
uh
design itself more or less through
through learning so lacoon just released
a position paper called a path towards
autonomous machine intelligence now i
admire lacoon a lot
i want to give him credit personally for
explaining things in very simple terms
it's always very insightful reading his
papers or listening to his lectures
note the lack of jargon um even with the
energy based models that the high-level
abstract pictorial formalism is
something which is great for
communicating science but not so great
if you don't want to get schmidt hubbard
but we'll come back to that in a bit
so um he really knows everything in his
space he can essentialize complex ideas
so yeah he's a wonderful scientist
however
let's not forget the i mean god knows he
must be earning about five million
dollars a year probably way more than
that as a vice president of facebook i
mean even at an e7 level he could
probably um into the millions so anyway
um
you know
i guess what i'm saying is he's not
going to rock the boat is he he's gonna
he's gonna stay uh comfortable they've
already gone quite far in introducing
the world to energy-based bayesian
bayesian models so um yeah that that's
the caveat anyway in his paper
he lamented that our best systems are
still far from matching human
reliability and real-world tasks such as
driving even after being fed with
ridiculous amounts of supervisory data
from human experts and after going
through millions of reinforcement
learning trials in virtual environments
and even after engineers had hardwired
hundreds of behaviors into the model
so lacoon thinks the answer may lie in
the ability of humans and many animals
to learn world models which is to say
internal predictive models of how the
world around us works i thought the
paper contained a lot of common sense
when it comes to some of the pitfalls of
the current approaches to agi and um you
know in my personal opinion i think he's
still a little bit too wedded to neural
networks but as we're going to discuss
in this program when it comes to
symbolism and empiricism uh there's no
middle way you're either all in or it's
like a house of cards and and it all
comes crashing down but anyway um
he thinks that the main challenges of ai
research today are being able to learn
passively
being able to learn efficiently
introducing type 2 models yeah of a
similar vein to our friend francois
charlay and um also this ability to
learn abstractions and compositional
semantics and i guess we should lump
those in together for the time being he
did actually recognize that
compositional semantics while important
were
um something that was you know it's
still beyond our reach he doesn't really
know how to achieve that with the
current paradigm
now um
on the blank slate you know the
prevailing wisdom from empiricists like
the [ __ ] and rich sutton remember his
bitter lake essay is that
all handcrafted knowledge is bad
basically and and you know perception
derived knowledge is the only knowledge
uh game in town
now um one thing i found quite ironic in
this paper is that it's a huge step away
from that wisdom i mean of course
they'll say that it isn't but when you
look at this
architecture diagram there was even a
comedy version of it made by um
christian sergei
it does look like a rich handcrafted
cognitive architecture um you know i
don't think it's hyperbolic to say it's
representing or resembling the
architectures that we used to build in
the 1980s of course lacoon would argue
that it's actually a level of
abstraction above that it's like a
prototypical architecture with learning
but in a way it's not because all of
those you know in all of those levels
levels of abstraction are actually
hard-coded levels of abstraction now
lacoone even showed a development graph
of human cognitive skills strongly
implied to be a directed acyclic graph
which was derived only from perceptual
information or nearly only now i thought
that was a bit of a sleight of hand
because he strongly suggests that the
sequential development of skills is
evidence of the blank slate in human
cognitive development but then he went
on to show that with these levels of
abstraction in his hierarchical models
they must be hard-coded this isn't to
say that he thinks that neural networks
today cannot learn deducible
abstractions from the base abstraction
prior or you know the the inductive pry
which is to say the encoder and the
prediction model you know um it did give
me pause for thought because presumably
he does think that current neural
networks can learn abstractions i mean
that's the common wisdom i mean in my
opinion they can't well they they learn
a tiny dot of abstractions out of an
infinite sea of of abstractions but it
gave me pause for thought and he also
said that he thought the current
language models were not artificial
general intelligence because they don't
have these abstract latent variables to
explore multiple interpretations of a
percept
and indeed search for an optimal course
of actions to achieve a goal so um
it's not entirely clear to me whether he
thinks that the lack of bayesian style
uncertainty quantification or the lack
of a hard coded abstraction hierarchy is
the biggest reason why it's not agi but
it's interesting to see him point out
those two um you know particular issues
that he sees with current architectures
for lacoon we need to be able to
dynamically switch between levels in an
abstraction hierarchy the levels should
strictly depend on the information
derived from the level below only and
the abstractions while handcrafted
should learn empirically by predicting
the representation of another concept in
the same level of the hierarchy but
pointing at another point in time or
space this is what lacoon means by
passive or self-supervised learning
now um
unfortunately we don't have time in this
episode to go into all of the jeppa
stuff but to be honest i'm glad we
didn't waste our time because yannick
has just made an episode on it so you
can think of this as supplementing
yannick's episode i do think it's quite
fascinating though i mean i'll say a
couple of things here lacoon introduces
these latent variables of unnormalized
energy to represent possible futures
it's basically as far as i'm concerned
it's analogous to bayesian style
probabilistic graphical models i mean
from a you know philosophy and
mental framework point of view uh you
know where you have these latent or
unobserved uh variables so and in the
context of lacoon's architecture we're
learning the dependency between what is
observed and what is not observed but
now we use this unnormalized energy
instead of pure probability
distributions which means that the
distributions don't have to sum up to
one because doing so is usually an
intractable operation um but it they are
actually interchangeable so you can
quite easily convert
energy distributions into probability
distribution you know obviously it's not
it's not a perfect conversion
it's still possible to use neural
networks as prediction modules in these
architectures and lacoon obviously would
want to do that the main change here is
that the models become stochastic over
the domain of the latent variable which
is to say there are many possible y's or
predictions for a given x or for a given
signal lacoon then regularizes the
latent to stop information leaking into
the predictions and also to shrink wrap
the representation around volumes of
high density um to i mean as lacoon says
mostly to overcome the curse of
dimensionality which you get with
so-called contrastive methods i always
wondered what lacoon meant by contrasted
versus non-contrastive
they're both contrast if they're both
the same but the non-contrastive has
some regularization tricks to prevent
mode collapse and to prevent
problems with the curse of
dimensionality anyway we discuss
self-supervised learning and contrasting
models quite a lot in our interview with
ishan mizra so why don't you go and
check that out if you're interested and
watch yannick's video as well anyway
all of his models um being you know
self-supervised con non-contrasting
models um learn by filling in the
missing gaps in time or space so they
work mostly passively and his models are
stacked vertically to capture concept or
abstraction hierarchies and then stacked
in time to learn these action space
abstractions which is what he calls you
know daniel kahneman style mode two or
you know thinking fast and slow so he
thinks that being able to find
trajectories in action space is
analogous to reasoning i don't think
it's analogous to well i mean i guess it
is technically analogous but it's at the
wrong level of description and you need
to have a an infinite number of
traversals to actually reason so i i
will make the argument later in the
video that what we need is is symbolics
and compositionality or what foda and
violation called um systematicity okay
um the paper also has some fascinating
discussion of uncertainty quantification
again we don't have time to get into it
here but i do recommend you check out
the paper i think it's a wonderful
you know tour de force of energy based
models and joint embedding prediction
architectures and and jan lacoon's view
on many topics in artificial general
intelligence
[Music]
everything comes from
observation from sensory input which is
which it has been crushed a long time
ago i'm even surprised i'm even
surprised
that
the likes of jan lacombe still think
that everything comes from observation i
mean
are you kidding i could be blind and
deaf and be as rational as don chomsky
and
god
we have another huge
part of cognition that has nothing to do
with perception
okay
the most remarkable quality of human
cognition the very core of our cognition
is the ability to take any two objects
and select from an infinite set of
possible abstractions
abstractions which are not deducible
from percepts
why does lacoon think that the only
abstractions which are needed are
directly deducible from perceptual
information
all of this fails when you consider the
fact that perception-derived data cannot
deduce most rules about the world
certainly not in limited time and space
i'm talking about world models and
abstractions and hierarchies
surely they cannot just be probabilities
now lecoon's architecture can produce a
tiny sliver of abstractions a minimum
spanning tree of which directly
deduceable from the handcrafted priors
of the encoders and the prediction
models
i agree that these are abstractions
but they are essentially human crafted
or at least human seeded
the space of possible abstractions
between two objects
is infinite
yes
infinite
lacoon said that objects may
spontaneously emerge
once the notion of object emerges in the
representation concepts like object
permanence may become easy to learn
objects that disappear behind others due
to parallax motion will invariably
reappear
so it was at this point that it occurred
to me uh what lacoon really meant by
abstractions and indeed i mean i can see
how three-dimensional objectiveness
might be deducible given the visual
priors that we've designed on these
models but this is just a drop in the
ocean
now lacoon admitted that it's these
handcrafted priors which determines what
is represented in the models and indeed
which abstractions are deducible
he said that the joint embedding
prediction architecture finds a
trade-off between the completeness and
the predictability of the
representations
what is predictable and what does not
get represented is determined implicitly
by the architectures of the encoders and
the predictors
they determine an inductive bias that
defines what information is predictable
or not
now lacun gives a concrete example of
these different levels of description or
abstraction if you like he says let's
take a concrete example
when driving a car given a proposed
sequence of actions on the steering
wheel and pedals over the next several
seconds
drivers can accurately predict the
trajectory of their car over the same
period
the details of the trajectory over
longer periods are harder to predict
because they may depend on other cars or
traffic lights or pedestrians and other
external events that are somewhat
unpredictable
but the driver can still make accurate
predictions at a higher level of
abstraction
ignoring the details of trajectories
other cars and traffic signals etc
now the car will probably arrive at its
destination within a predictable time
frame the detailed trajectory will be
absent from this level of description
but the approximate trajectory as drawn
on a map is represented a discrete
latent variable may be used to represent
multiple alternative routes
end quote so lacoon goes on to say that
a model could in theory work at multiple
levels of description or abstraction
simultaneously just like humans do and
he asserted that the ability to
represent world states at several levels
of abstraction
is essential to intelligent behavior
yan lacoon reasoning is simply finding a
good path through a state action space
this is a very low resolution view of a
complex topic it's the equivalent of
predicting the weather tomorrow using
the average temperature of this month
deep learning folks tend to lean into
the parlor tricks and lean away from any
mechanistic understanding
lacun admits there is an exponential
blow up traversing state action spaces
in his hierarchical joint embedding
architecture and suggests using a
discrete approximate dynamic programming
algorithm like monte carlo tree search
to find good trajectories in tractable
time but a much better way to cut down
the search space is with
compositionality
compositionality
is that the meaning of a complex
expression is fully determined by its
structure and the meanings of its
constituents once we fix what the parts
mean and how they're put together we
have no more leeway regarding the
meaning of the whole this is the
principle of compositionality a
fundamental presupposition of most
contemporary work in semantics or the
study of meaning
we can understand a large perhaps
infinitely large collection of complex
expressions the first time we encounter
them and if we understand some complex
expressions we tend to understand others
that can be obtained by recombining
their constituents and guess what this
doesn't just apply to expressions this
also applies to planning and reasoning
this is only possible with an algebraic
approach to semantics and planning and
achieved with symbolic manipulation
for any two physical objects x and y if
y is contained in x then if nothing
exceptional happened to y
the location of y must be the location
of x
now this is a symbolic rule a function a
procedure
you cannot represent this fact without
symbolic logic this isn't data but
rather a procedure which needs
verification you have variables of a
specific type where types come from an
ontological structure and second you
have quantification over these variables
that's what the upside down a means it's
addressing a potentially infinite set of
possible values
neural networks are extensional they
cannot represent intentional which is to
say infinite objects
now if you want a refresher on this
stuff check out our intro to the gary
marcus and louis lamb show
it's good to be in an environment where
people take for granted these questions
because i spent a lot of the last 20
years almost
even more than 20 years trying to get
people to recognize the importance of
abstraction so i i came to this
having worked in psychology on children
learning rule and
came into the first way or second wave
depending on how you kind of of neural
networks and and people trying to argue
that there was no abstraction that it
was all just basically memorization
through
multi-layer networks they were then
three-layer network and it's been a long
hard slog to get people to realize how
important abstraction is and i i think
that there's been a real sea change in
the last couple of years
the important thing to realize is the
only way to represent infinite objects
in a finite way
is using quantification or logic over
tight symbolic structures
that's why neural networks cannot do
basic arithmetic you need intentions
that are symbolic procedures over
variables
let's look at another example addition
here's a program add zero n equals n
add m n equals one plus add m minus one
n
now it's a finite representation of an
infinite object
so addition of m to n is nothing more
than adding m ones to n or m successors
to n
and from that you can define
multiplication because multiplying m by
m is adding m n's or adding n ms that's
why it's commutative yeah the
i mean compositionality which i i i'm
very excited to hear terms like
compositionality being discussed
as of late hey i mean that
that's music to my ears
but there were
huge results that were uh
mathematically done that show that
compositionality actually
evolved for survival reasons even
the their examples they give is usually
language like as you speak you're
interpreting and understanding what i'm
saying
practically nearly real part
now let me let me put that into you and
let me make you appreciate the
complexity here
you're taking a sequence of sounds in
this case because i'm speaking it could
be written i'm taking the sequence of
words
and you're almost real time building
a mental picture of what that i'm saying
the thought that i'm trying to convey
right
if we didn't have compositionality
you know
it would every so if
in the absence of compositionality you
know what you have to do every time you
have to go and grab a sequence a drop
sequence and make a meaning for it then
make a meaning for the whole thing
if you didn't have rules for subparts
already built in
and you just say oh they just said a
phrase they just said appraise i know
how to build a meaning for that one and
then
i do three four operations in the three
and i'm done
if every time you have to try all the
parts that should fit together
you wouldn't understand me real time we
couldn't have communicated
and here's the genius of richard
montague
who mathematically showed i mean people
don't appreciate the work that these
guys did you know it's all uh
it's all a large language model now but
look look at what richard montague did
he said
i can have
john
uh likes to play guitar
i can have
the boy next door likes to play guitar i
can have
my uncle's
nephew who lives in australia likes to
play guitar you get my point
montague said how could all these things
john
heed
the guy next door how could they all
have the same semantic type in the end
because they fit in the same slot
the genius of montego is to devise an
algebra
that no matter what you have here
it will reduce when you do all the
typing
to e and entity
that's compositional semantics there's
been a lot of people
uh
who who've been sort of
saying there is a limitation to deep
learning let's say or machine learning
more generally
because it's obvious that those things
basically do curve fitting what's our
definition of reasoning
uh what is the the process by which we
elaborate models and is there a
qualitative difference
between
a models that merely performs curve
feeding
as we normally know it
and a model that has a
let's say to to adopt a terminology that
others have proposed
that models that establish sort of a
causal model of the the data you're
observing
uh which can be the basis for for
reasoning and and things like that right
um
and the answer to this is probably no
there is a difference of course but is
it an essential qualitative difference
i'm not entirely sure
and then there is the the argument
if there is a qualitative difference
which i'm not sure about um
would this qualitative difference be in
the form of
uh fundamentally different things from
deep learning you know things that are
you know like discrete symbolic
reasoning or things of that type and to
that my answer is clearly no i do not
believe that's the case
okay we were going to publish the show
today and look what you again schmidt
huber has just dropped on his blog he
said that yan lacoon's 2022 paper on
autonomous machine intelligence
rehashes but does not cite essential
work of his lab from 1990 to 2015.
now you again schmidt uber has
established a bit of a reputation for
constantly saying that
all of the current ideas that are being
published in deep learning today
were already done previously in his lab
and he feels resentful that he hasn't
had proper attribution he says he's not
without uh conflict here and it might
seem self-interested you know correcting
the record like this but the truth of
the matter is that he says yes it is
self-interested much of the closely
related work pointed to below was done
in his lab and he wishes to be
acknowledged and recognized he's
basically resentful that he didn't get
the turing award along with the other
godfathers to be honest i personally do
think of schmidhuber as one of the
godfathers
so he quotes lacoon many ideas described
in this paper almost all of them have
been formulated by many authors in
various contexts in various forms and
then schmidt uber says yes in fact
unfortunately much of the paper reads
like deja vu of the papers from his lab
going all the way back to 1990 without
any citations so i'm scrolling down here
mentions of controllers world models
planning and roll out indeed this was
covered in schmidt hoover's papers um
he's famously argued that gans for
example adversarial learning is a
specialized specialization of one of his
earlier models which he released from
his lab
lacoon's idea about learning to act by
observation so lacoon has this hierarchy
of data streams with increasing amounts
of agency and being a radical empiricist
lacoon thinks that we learn everything
we know about the world largely by
observation and mostly by not
interacting with the world around us
schmidt huber says that the recurrent
predictive world model which may be good
at predicting some things but uncertain
about others so this is this thing at
the top here so schmidt hubba thinks
that he's already been there and done
that
this idea of the hierarchical percepts
as well he says in 1991 the neural
sequence chunker which is to say the
neural history compressor used
unsupervised learning and predictive
coding in a deep hierarchy of recurrent
neural networks so he thinks he's done
that as well
most interesting for me he commented on
the symbolic component of jan's paper so
do we need symbols for reasoning and he
said that he had previously argued of
the importance of incorporating
inductive biases into neural networks
that enable them to efficiently learn
about symbols now
based on the violation paper i think
that's an oxymoron but he said that many
neural networks suffer from a binding
problem which affects their ability to
dynamically and flexibly combined which
is to say
bind information that is distributed
throughout the neural network as is
required to effectively form represent
and relate symbol-like entities
he said he released a 2020 position
paper which offers a conceptual
framework for addressing this problem
and provides an in-depth analysis of the
challenges and requirements and
corresponding inductive biases required
for symbolic manipulation to emerge
naturally in neural networks i must
admit i've not read that paper i'm
interested to check it out now
so i'm just reading the abstract of that
paper now on the binding problem in
artificial neural networks um it was uh
primary author klaus gref from the
google brain team uh also with schmidt
huber in 2020
so it said that contemporary neural
networks fall short of human level
generalization
which allows them to extend far beyond
their experiences
and they put it down to this binding
problem which they say affects the
capacity to acquire a compositional
understanding of the world in terms of
symbol like entities like objects by the
way this is exactly what we're talking
about in this show which they say is
crucial for generalizing in predictable
and systematic ways
to address this issue they propose a
unifying framework that resolves around
forming meaningful entities from
unstructured sensory inputs
maintaining the separation of
information at representational level so
um yeah i guess we'll get back to you on
that whether it's
whether it's any good
lacoon said that the centerpiece of the
paper is the joint embedding prediction
architecture jeppa and the main
advantage of japa is that it performs
predictions in representation space
assuring the need to predict every
detail of why he says
in 1997 a quarter of a century ago
he built a general adversarial
reinforcement learning machine that
could ignore many or all of these
details and ask arbitrary abstract
questions with computable answers in
representation space
and he also noted that our even or his
even earlier less general approach to
artificial curiosity since 1991
naturally direct the world model towards
representing predictable details in the
environment
schmidt uber said given his comments
above he doesn't see any significant
novelty there
he's not claiming that everything is
solved but he said in the last 32 years
we've already made substantial progress
along the lines proposed by lacoon
in his paper lacoon said below is an
attempt to connect the present proposal
with relevant prior work and schmidhuber
said he cited a few somewhat related
things while ignoring most of the
directly relevant original work as
mentioned above possibly encouraged by
an award that he and his colleagues
shared for inventions of other
researchers whom they did not cite
he said that the point is that these
ideas are not as new as they may be
understood by reading lacoon's paper
there's a lot of prior work that is
directly along the lines proposed in his
lab
we've not had a great experience with
him we tried to invite him on the
podcast and he did seem initially
interested and then he suddenly demanded
a fee for coming on and then i did
actually offer him five thousand dollars
just for 60 minutes of his time and that
wasn't enough apparently so the main
thing i don't like about this is is the
tone of it frankly i think it's really
easy just to go back in time and say oh
i i invented something which is
conceptually similar to this because
many things are conceptually similar
we've just made a whole show on the
infinitude of abstraction space i will
hand it to schmidhuber that they are
very similar but the architecture and
approach that lacoon is presenting here
is different it's using uh modern
methods it's not using rnns for example
yes it's using the same abstract ideas
in fact what i like about lacun is that
he presents all of his work in an
abstract way the pictorial formalism of
energy-based models is very abstract
that's what makes it understandable the
way he describes contrastive and
self-supervised learning is very
abstract he's talking about predicting
unobserved information from observed
information and he uses a language which
is very accessible to lots of people so
i can understand why other researchers
would look at it and say oh that's
basically the same as what i've done but
that's because he's talking in the
abstract if you look at his physical
models they are different in my opinion
lacoon has been a huge advocate of
passive or so-called self-supervised
learning
supervisioning
sucks i mean it's very limited in the
sense that you can train machines to do
very specific tasks and because they're
trying to reverse very specific tasks
they're going to use all the biases that
are in the data to uh to do that task
and if you try to get um outside of that
tags they're not going to perform very
well that's a limitation of supervised
learning it has absolutely nothing to do
with deep learning
and this has been a complaint of mine
for a while about um
you know let's say the dominant
paradigms of neural networks is from my
perspective is a bayesian okay they've
always been essentially maximum
likelihood
estimators it's like okay i train my
neural network to take in a whole bunch
of inputs and to give me the one true
value
you know which is really just the
maximum kind of likelihood computation
of
of my inputs and you know as a bayesian
it's like i mean guys that's just an
estimate you know like the real truth is
it's a distribution
like there are many possible you know
output values that this input should
have given me it's sort of
maybe it's 75 percent this value and and
a little bit less percent that or it's a
continuum you know if it's a if it's a
density function or whatever so of
course it is and like this is the nature
of reality is that there's uncertainty
and
and you know when you're trying to build
models if you want them to be
generalizable like they have to they
have to unders they have to
encode in some way this type of this
uncertainty right otherwise you're
always just using the the mle or you
know whatever some other kind of
statistical projection of that of that
distribution you're throwing out
information you're losing a lot of
information so i totally agree that um
that uh
neural networks
or that you know the paradigm needs to
evolve to take much more account of of
uncertainty i think where i kind of
object to it is why aren't we just using
the word probability okay like because
if we don't
embrace
so
let's suppose you agree okay we need to
start allowing for multiple
possibilities
great
now you need a mathematics to deal with
multiple
possibilities we already have a
mathematics to deal with multiple
possibilities it's called probability
theory or better yet conditional
probability theory we've got that
mathematics it's we have
hundreds of years of you know
development and theory behind that let's
let's use it because if you don't use it
if you don't just admit that what you're
doing is probability theory
then you're rolling your own probability
theory and just like the fuzzy logic
people that kind of did the same kind of
thing you're gonna wind up with all
kinds of inconsistencies and problems or
whatever because for better or worse
we only have one mathematically rigorous
and consistent
theory of uncertainty and it is
probability theory
that's just what it is it's conditional
probability theory
yeah but devil's advocate i mean lacoon
has been challenged on this before i
mean this is with his energy-based
models
where the the punch line is that rather
than have the normalized probability
which means it sums up to one you store
these these exponential energies and
lacoon says well i don't care about
calibration which means i don't ever
want to compare my models with other
with other models and also i only ever
want to make decisions and he also says
that if you if you ever have a
normalized probability distribution in
high dimensions the model is probably
wrong anyway and he gives the example of
some density that has a manifold of zero
width where if you sample that density
you'll never ever get any samples on the
manifold anyway so he said what you want
to do is regularize it as he does with
his energy-based models and that's what
you end up with anyway
yeah i mean there's a lot of things to
to say about that i mean and as you can
imagine like having
the fact that probability theory is
centuries old like you know these these
questions have been addressed already
like in the in the
like let's say bayesian literature or uh
probability theory literature so
all this stuff has already been talked
about and addressed for a long time so
first of all
if if a probability is is meaningless
and high dimensions so is its logarithm
which is the the energy function right i
mean you don't you don't gain anything
by ignoring the problem like you can
ignore it but then you wind up with with
inconsistencies as far as as not needing
to
normalize the distribution well if you
want to if you ever want to add two
probabilities together
you better normalize your distributions
and in fact he does do that like it was
like yeah i need to do this kind of
trajectory sampling i need to do some
normalization here with like give
sampling or whatever to actually do the
normalization so i can add up different
trajectories and you know calculate some
means and things like that and as far as
not doing model comparison
well so here's here's something that's
important to understand is that from a
bayesian perspective any of this
regularization stuff that machine
learning people try to do all the time
that's model comparison you know if
you're what you're trying to do is say
i'm comparing a model a and a model b
where model a has hopefully fewer
parameters or it's simpler in some you
know some way okay which one should i
prefer in light of the evidence like how
much can i regularly regularize it and
still fit the data well that's model
comparison at least that's what a
bayesian would call you know model
comparison and we have a mathematics for
how to do that like you have to conduct
these integrals and i get it that's hard
okay like
totally understand believe me i've been
there done that tried that it's really
hard okay you wind up with these
multi-dimensional intervals they're
really hard but just
ignoring it and then forgetting about it
and going back to maximum likelihood
estimation like
you know you're not going to make any
advances there where i see cool advances
made is when people embrace it they say
okay
i got to do this integral here
can't it's really intractable but here's
some approximations to it okay but i but
i know what i'm trying to do i'm trying
to approximate this specific integral
and i can come up with really nice
approximations under these set of
criteria it gives you a whole
theoretical foundation right to advance
the approximations rather than just
giving up and going over into energy
land and doing arbitrary hacks and
approximations for which you have no
theory really like that's why we end up
with all these things in machine
learning like
this kind of batch norm that batch norm
why does batch norm even work people
arguing about it should we do it should
we not do they have no theoretical
foundation it's just hacking right yeah
well it's quite ironic because um
uh even jan lacoon himself you know he
he wants to have end-to-end
gradient-based systems but he even
admits that on his joint embedding
prediction architecture you know there's
a there's a hierarchical one for for
stacking the concepts and there's also
um what he calls a mode two daniel
kahneman style one which is where you
have this discrete action space and you
learn abstractions of actions over time
and of course he needs to add these
probabilities together to to generate
trajectories through this action space
so um he what does he do he uses the um
the the gibbs uh sampling conversion and
it's the same thing all along you know
because we've got this discrete action
space he can't use a gradient-based
method to to do the um the traversal
search so he has to use monte carlo to
research so and and obviously he's also
an empiricist and a blank slate guy and
um he's he's creating this very very
complex and and highly specific
cognitive architecture which reminded me
of the systems in the 1980s so you know
it it's uh not quite as puritanical as
as you would think
yeah i know well one thing i really
respect about mcconnell is that he's a
pragmatist right and so
at the end of the day like he really
cares about things that work and you
know and i have to think a large part of
what he's doing here is um
trying to get the the
let's say the orthodox machine learning
community to move in a certain direction
right to improve these systems
but
but he's got to do so kind of gently has
to guide them you know maybe one step at
a time and avoiding trigger words like
you know let's not say
probability because like maybe that
triggers somebody or or
no bayesian because that'll trigger
somebody i don't know i mean it's
so it's gonna they're moving in the
right right direction let me just say
that it's just that uh it's maybe things
are gonna be a bit slower than they need
to be because we're not embracing a lot
of the theoretical results that
that already exist and instead of
tackling some of the really hard
problems we're sort of like trying to
avoid them temporarily by you know but
it's okay like i mean eventually the
truth will out right like people will
will get this um yeah so what was that
fractions analogy for energy based
models
well i was just i was just thinking you
know
this idea that hey we're working with
probabilities we can just ignore
the normalization right and just work
with the energies is almost like
somebody coming along and saying
you know whenever i'm doing arithmetic
like adding fractions it's such a pain
because i have to have the same
denominator every time i add the
fractions together you know and when the
denominators get to be these really big
integers i have to do this massive
multi-digit
multiplication you know forget that like
i'm just going to add the numerators and
just ignore the denominators right it's
like
okay you know you can do that but you're
doing a completely different function
you know it's like the the median of two
fractions is you add the numerators
together and you add the denominators
together right and i think it has a name
like uh
you know freshman edition or something
because it's a common mistake to do
right
i mean that's that's what it seems like
to me it's like let's ignore all the
hard work
and just just do kind of a hack and it
just doesn't work like it introduces
problems
what do you think lacoon would say
though to that
well i think he he says i mean he you
know in the paper itself like there are
many scenarios where you can't ignore
the normalization and like he kind of
admits that and and uses it in certain
places but but that's just bayesian
bayesian probability at that point it's
like bayesians don't have any problem
you know understanding that there is a
normalization constant sometimes you can
work without it
sometimes you can't and so they'll defer
normalization until necessary but the
problem is
there's so many scenarios where
normalization is required so many useful
scenarios i want to comment on on
something interesting you brought up
there which is um
you know this like the the desire to
have differentiable um
learning methods
i totally get that desire i wish i wish
we had differentiable
methods to find like program search in
general okay like
where i where i run into a problem with
it is that um
he talks a lot about world models right
and he says that
that the big problem that's going to be
facing ai in the future is how do we
build these world models like how do we
how do we represent them how do we build
them how do we learn them well here's
something to think about here which
occurred to me when i was reading that
paper is
hey a lot of the world that we're
operating in right now that we want to
model and understand for better or worse
consists of symbolic computational
systems
like pretty much every single program in
existence today is a symbolic piece of
code
running in a you know von neumann
machine some kind of like you know
finite kind of turing machine kind of
thing it's running these symbolic
systems like they're all over the place
okay and whether we like it or not
people's cognition at a high level is
pretty much
symbolic it may be implemented at the
lowest level by by
sub-symbolic nano things or whatever but
but we operate in this kind of symbolic
thing we're surrounded by symbolic
machines okay and programs and software
well your world model is going to need
to be able to model those things
and i'm really skeptical that
i mean if if we're trying to model
symbolic systems
are we really hopeful that we can model
them well enough with
non-symbolic differentiable systems you
know i'm pretty skeptical i think we
have to just grab the bull
by the horns as they would say just
embrace the fact that we've got to
figure out
how to do search over these discrete
spaces i don't know how to i don't know
how to do it nobody knows how to do it
but we got to figure that out you know
whether it's some evolutionary
algorithms or whatever the case is if we
can
crack the nut of learning how to do
searches over the space of all possible
programs
outside of the space that's differential
differentiably accessible
that's you know we're gonna make like
huge project there with progress there
right whether it's dreamcoder or
something else you know i don't know
neat you know neuroevolutionary
topologies whatever it is we need to put
much more effort into learning how to
search that space that's not
differentiably accessible
i agree and i think it's easy just to
say that like there are other challenges
as well i mean lacuna
said in the paper as well that just
something as simple as being able to
take a goal and break it down into
intermediate sub goals at different
levels of description we just take stuff
like that for granted yeah and it's as
simple with you know like the the
problem in cognitive science of these
categories just being able to draw
circles around things at different
levels of description and traverse
between them we take that for granted
so professor yan the [ __ ] recently
released an article called what ai can
tell us about intelligence can deep
learning systems learn to manipulate
symbols the answers might change our
understanding of how intelligence works
and what makes humans unique now this is
pretty much in direct response to some
of the hype in the ai community he does
have a huge stab actually not only at
gary marcus which is about symbols but
there are many other kind of um
fronts being fought in the world of ai
at the moment but yeah i mean now's the
time that there's so much [ __ ] in
the deep learning and
at the moment we almost need to create a
[ __ ] bingo card and what have we got
on that card well some people think
scaling is all you need well yanderkoon
agrees that that's [ __ ] some people
think that reward is enough well yan
lacoon also thinks that that's [ __ ]
some people think that ai systems today
are slightly conscious yan le [ __ ]
thinks that that's [ __ ] some people
think that ai systems understand us
yan lacoon thinks that's [ __ ] as
well
some people think that deep learning can
do symbolics well yet yamba [ __ ] thinks
that it can gary marcus thinks that it
can't some people think that data is all
you need some people think that
emergence is all you need um anyway i
mean i was really impressed when i read
this article from jan because in a way i
was i was really happy that he was
calling [ __ ] on so many of these ai
hypsters you know stuff that i perceive
to be [ __ ] but i think it's very
unfair towards gary marcus because
unlike open ai that's been spouting all
of this utter nonsense gary marcus just
has a different perspective there are so
many different perspectives of
artificial general intelligence and gary
marcus has the same perspective as noam
chomsky which is that psychology has a
lot to say about artificial general
intelligence and yes maybe he has a
philosophical agenda maybe he even has a
monetary agenda because if the focus
changed to his view of artificial
general intelligence he could create a
startup company he can become as
successful as jan lacoon has but i think
it's very unfair to criticize gary
marcus in this way because gary marcus
still has his credibility intact now on
to chapter two this is the emergent
abilities of large language models
so there's an interesting paper just out
called emergent abilities of large
language models by jason way etau
now
they say
scaling up language models has been
shown to predictively improve
performance and sample efficiency on a
wide range of downstream tasks
this paper they say discusses the
unpredictable phenomena
which they refer to as the emergent
ability of large language models and
they consider an ability to be emerging
if it's not present in smaller models
but is present in larger models thus
emergent abilities cannot be predicted
simply by extrapolating the performance
of smaller models now um i think i don't
really like their definition i think a
better definition would be a transient
change in phenomena right so it's it's
not the it's not the relationship
between small models and large models
because if there was a kind of
continuous improvement in perplexity no
one would call that emergent so yeah i
think my definition of emergence and
we've been thinking a lot about
emergence because we just did a show on
it is an unexpected and transient change
in macroscopic phenomena
that's the best definition that i can
come up with personally now in this
paper they seem to have the in my view
incorrect impression that emergence is
the same thing as extrapolation
similar to that grocking paper a while
ago all of the long-term misquote this
all the time they say oh there's this
sudden snap point where the perplexity
goes down the validation accuracy goes
up and suddenly the model can
extrapolate and i don't think that's
really true it doesn't pass the sanity
test to me i mean
it's just a quirk of optimization that
the model suddenly fits the data set
better that's not the same thing as
extrapolation right extrapolation means
that i can i can fit functions outside
of the training range but the problem is
it's quite easy to measure with things
like arithmetic but it's quite difficult
to measure with some of the um you know
language tasks like for example on big
bench because many of these things don't
exist in the training data and it's very
difficult to measure them so the whole
concept of extrapolation becomes very
vague with some of these language models
and assuming it's not extrapolation why
is it so surprising and why is it so
interesting that we have a sudden jump
in perplexity i just don't get it
it's i don't think it's that big of a
deal honestly
definitely interesting
definitely requires further examination
but um
i think this is the main
argument which is used by these folks
that talk about scaling laws these
emergentists who think that if only we
could train for longer or if only we
could train on more data or on bigger
models then suddenly we'll get this snap
and we'll get this recursive
self-improving artificial general
intelligence that just doesn't make any
sense to me i genuinely don't believe
that
chapter 3 on empiricism
chomsky argued that the way we actually
acquire the faculty of language and
therefore its relationship to experience
and indeed the physical world
radically different from the empiricist
tradition
chomsky became well known for his famous
1950s critique of behavioral psychology
now behavioral psychologists tended to
believe that humans were an
unadulterated blank slate made of putty
which was then molded and shaped by our
environment you know through a process
of empirical stimulus and response
they believed that simple reinforcement
learning was how we modeled the world
around us indeed how we learn language
now chomsky argued that this could not
possibly explain how virtually all human
beings regardless of their intelligence
do something as miraculous as master the
faculty of language even when they're
not deliberately taught it as most
people probably aren't
and they also do this at such an
extraordinarily young age and in such an
extraordinarily short space of time he
argued that for this to happen at all we
must be genetically pre-programmed to do
it and therefore all human languages
must have in common a basic structure
which corresponds to this
pre-programming as brian mcgee pointed
out in his 1970s bbc interview of
chomsky this also has some very negative
implications chief of which is that
anything which can't be accommodated to
the structure any piece of the cosmic
jigsaw puzzle which can't connect with
other pieces are linguistically
inexpressible and unintelligible to us
so the general principles common to all
languages set vital limits to our
capacity to understand the world and
communicate with each other but chomsky
would argue that this is the very basis
for our creative capacity to understand
an infinite space of abstractions and
also understand anything which has been
expressed by another human being
centrally your whole approach represents
a rejection of the empirical tradition
in in philosophy it doesn't because i
mean the very fact that you think that
uh the empiricists our role about how we
learn
uh must mean that they're wrong about
knowledge and uh the nature of knowledge
and the nature of knowledge has been the
central problem in the whole empirical
tradition of philosophy
well uh
the classical empiricist tradition which
i think was the tradition that's
represented let's say perhaps in its
highest form by hume
uh seems to me to be a
a
a tradition of extreme importance when
we investigate it i think we discover
that it's just completely false that is
that the mechanisms that he discussed
are not the mechanisms by which the mind
reaches states of knowledge that the
states of knowledge attained are
radically different than the kinds that
he discussed for example for hume
the mind was in his image
a kind of a theater in which
ideas paraded across the stage
and
we it therefore followed necessarily
that we could introspect completely into
the contents of our mind
if an idea is not on the stage it's not
in the mind
uh and the ideas may be connected and
associated well that's a that's a theory
and in fact it's a theory that has had a
an enormous grip on the imagination
throughout most of the history of
western thought for example that that
same image dominates the rationalist
tradition as well
uh where it was assumed that one could
exhaust the contents of the mind by
careful attention chomsky was inspired
by continental rationalism which refers
to a set of views more or less shared by
a number of philosophers who are active
on the european continent during the
latter two thirds of the 17th century
and the beginning of the 18th century
rationalism basically defines your view
of knowledge as a rationalist you
consider the primacy of reason and
intuition over sensation and perceptual
experience
you would tend to think that most ideas
rules and knowledge are innate and just
like our friend dr walid sabha you would
eschew any type of uncertainty
quantification you would prefer to deal
with absolute black and white certainty
anything else as far as you are
concerned wouldn't be knowledge
so on the on the discord community i i
made the statement that knowledge cannot
be entirely derivable from perceptual
information and and they just they were
having none of it actually most abstract
mathematical knowledge right is is far
faster than human experience right so
there's this kind of dualism it's what i
call the mind experience dualism so now
given the apparatus we have we can we
can kind of interconvert between uh
perceptual experience and mathematically
abstract experience if you take all of
our perceptual
uh
cognitive uh powers
i think if you want to draw a venn
diagram it's a dot
in a huge right the abstract word is
much much it's
all experiential knowledge is is almost
a tiny dot in that ocean
and you know what they're doing now in
ai they're concentrating on the damn dot
no no learning from instances
is brutal guys so when you want to
defend it you have to tell me how uh
hold on
you have to tell me look learning from
data either you're adopted and defended
or you don't there's no middle right if
you want to defend learning from
observations a template like this you
have to convince me how a child
learns 200 million sentences from few
examples if you don't have an
explanation for that
the rest is hand waving
well waleed sabha thinks that empiricism
is a huge house of cards as soon as you
allow any symbolic manipulation the
whole thing just falls down flat on its
face so according to walid saber um if
you have to be an empiricist you have to
be an empiricist all the way
and let me uh
make an example out of this
you take a guy that lives in bangladesh
you take a guy that lives in amsterdam
hall
perception wise observation wise
empirical data wise
they're
apart so much that they live practically
on different planets
but what they know is the same knowledge
that is not empirically obtained
is the same
and that's all they need to survive
their observation their individual
four-year-old knows
that if i say i'll have a greek statue
in every room in my house they know i'm
not talking about a greek statue what i
mean is in every room in my house i have
a greek study and because they know this
is knowledge not from observation that a
physical object cannot be in more than
one location
but that requires symbolic manipulation
devil's advocate though let's imagine
i'm playing a computer game and you can
have the same statue in two rooms at the
same time so
let's say it's a blue statue and and i'm
observing lots of episodes of this game
and i very quickly learn that you can
have this statue simultaneously in two
different rooms but not both in the same
room i could then create a cognitive
program and i've just empirically
learned that program no i i challenge
you to have to to even
to even think it
look at tim i mean
even in the world of star trek where
they you know transportation can be i
mean we can just
decompose all our molecules and
transport them and reassemble them and
all that stuff
even in that world of sci-fi
there are things that the mind cannot
even accept right these are this is how
the universe works
so i challenge you to imagine the two
blue statues in two different rooms as
one
you can't even think it
i think some of this comes down to these
you know modern matters of definition
right and and black and white lines so i
mean traditionally
a uh a dimension on which empiricists
and rationalists
differ is the degree to which they admit
the existence of
innate knowledge or an eight and eight
concepts and so
obviously on on one extreme is
is zero and then that would be
like an ultra empiricist who says
there's no such thing as any kind of
innate
you know knowledge like literally uh
let's see if we're talking the unit of
analysis is the human an individual
human mind that they start as some type
of literal zero
blank slate and then through
just
empirical observation alone
um
learn right
and then on on kind of the other extreme
you know
i don't think rationalists have ever
denied that there
that some knowledge is empirical like i
don't i don't know that they've ever
denied that but perhaps the extreme
version there
is that they they say there's a kind of
superiority
to
deduced rationally derived knowledge
versus
empirical knowledge so like in a way you
know like the the uh
platonic ideals are in a sense
more reliable and and more superior and
and
and you know more ultimate or purer than
than any type of empirical knowledge i
mean i think any of us probably should
know that the answer is
somewhere in between here and where the
dividing line is between
okay if you go beyond this you know you
you become a
a rationalist instead of an empiricist
i'm not sure like i don't know where
they they draw the kind of battle lines
today but i think if we
if we take say look
as
an empiricist
he he admits that there is
prior knowledge you know you need these
inductive priors to be
quite useful after all one of his huge
achievements was cnn i.e structurally
encoding a certain kind of
of prior this translation and variance
into neural networks
but he thinks it should be
as close to zero as possible that it
should be so minimal that it's like just
enough to kind of
uh jump start or bootstrap a learning
system and then from then on it can kind
of just learn everything on its own
through observation of of data
and i think people on the other side of
the camp and i include my myself there
pretty much and i think wally too
is that
we believe that the
there's just not enough data not enough
data not enough computational resources
not enough time
uh for that to make sense that sure
there are a lot of concepts a lot of
knowledge that you can learn by
by observation and then and then you
know reasoning kind of on top of that
um
and by the way empiricists now no longer
deny that that reasoning happens right
but they view reasoning as just
generating
connections between facts that were
learned empirically not as bringing
facts to the table themselves but really
only as mechanisms connecting and
deriving from
from facts um i just think that the
that it's not realistic it's not
pragmatic you know in the same way that
sure a neural network of infinite size
like axi exercise you know the axi folks
can do everything well that's not what
i'm interested in i'm interested in
pragmatic systems and
i think that there's
types of knowledge that are derived from
um
rational sources you know these
deductive logical kinds of sources
that uh you can't hope to get to
pragmatically from
empiricism alone and what fascinates me
is
okay what's the mechanism then by which
that knowledge
entered into into our brains like that
to me is is the fascinating question
yeah i mean i want to get to that in a
second because i know you've got some
very interesting ideas about um
fristen's free energy principle actually
and it relating to our existence but i
don't think lacuna or even jeff hawkins
you remember jeff hawkins i mean he um
cited vernon mount castle you know that
famous neuroscientist from the 1980s uh
this idea that the the neocortex has all
of these um little units that are
exactly the same they're just wired
differently but that's still a prior so
he said that we had
um you know some of our neurons were fed
from our sensory motor circuits and then
there were other neurons that were kind
of like concept neurons but if you think
about it the way the brain is structured
is still a prior so any conception that
we have
you know you were just saying before
that empiricists think that there's a
stage and all of the ideas we have are
derived from things which are on the
stage and if you look at the brain it's
a stage right all of that sensory motor
signaling it's a stage
so i don't think they would really deny
that the structure of that stage defines
a lot of our conception
yeah i i can't put words in their mouth
but i i don't think they deny that i i
would i would hope to think that
that they don't i mean because because
it's obvious that there that there is
structure there and i think and as i
said i think lacoon has agreed that
you know sure there is some initial
structure that you that you need in
order to get you know bootstrapped if
you will um
i think uh you know maybe if if we talk
about in terms of say something simpler
which is just logic gates like if you
just imagine
that your brain was
consisted only of nand you know one of
the logic gates that can create any any
logical operation so
whatever you just have trillions of you
know nand gates and if you connected
them up in a potentially
fully connected way so every single nand
gate connected to every other possible
mandate
and then and then the goal of learning
is to turn off and on
some of those connections um such that
you wind up with
something useful
um i think
the question is just how much do you
have to start with like you know maybe
if you just start with a random
knockout so i just randomly assign a
bunch of a bunch of connections you know
can i learn you know can i then learn
from that through some type of back
propagation or some other
you know weird because now we're in like
a digital space you know some type of ea
algorithm you know can it can it learn
things or do you need to have like some
additional kind of structure on there
because if you look at the human brain
it's way way way far
away from that extreme of a fully
connected
you know nan circuitry like it's very
sparse
it has you know
structure in these kind of cortical
columns like hawkins talks about you
know in a very certain
kind of vertical and also horizontally
parallelized way you know there's tons
and tons of structure there like it's in
the kind of distance of all possible
networks it's a very long way from a
fully connected tabular
with just random connections right
so i think that i think that they have
to admit that there's there's structure
there i think it's just that
they want it to be as lightweight and
and as
you know the constraints to be as loose
as possible because then that allows as
much flexibility to that
that learning algorithm to to learn
things
that are most optimized and most
appropriate
for any particular task
yeah yeah i agree with that and when
walid was talking about cognitive
templates earlier his main rationale is
he doesn't want to be surprised by
reality so he says that you know what we
call someone who
um makes poor predictions about the
world we call them crazy that's what
wally would say but i don't entirely
agree with that because i know that i
could i put this to him i could have a
computer simulation and in this
simulation
the physics are different the reality is
different so i could quickly come up
with a cognitive template in my mind
that in this computer world you can have
two blue objects simultaneously existing
in two different rooms and i would very
quickly learn that cognitive template
and i could reason over it so i have
just empirically come up with a new
cognitive template
right
i mean i agree because you don't even
have to imagine simulations for for very
strange and i think this is kind of what
chomsky gets at when he says that we
have this innate radical empiricism
right is we have this this false belief
that
concepts that we learn at the at the
scale of pool balls and you know apples
falling from trees and things like that
just we feel strongly that they must
also apply to electrons and protons and
atoms and you know whatever else and
they just don't i mean
like that's like even take a simple
concept of you know oh
two objects cannot exist at the same
place at the same time well
that's true if they're fermions you know
if they're bosons like a photon for
example you can have as many photons as
you want in the same place at the same
at the same time right so i mean
physics alone and just like the world in
general or take a you know mixing colors
if you mix
pigments together
um you know red and green pigment for
example is going to going to wind up
with kind of like a brownish you know
muck or whatever but red and green light
produce yellow so i mean you get all
kinds of almost
antithetical or opposite you know
behaviors of things that happen all
throughout the natural world and i don't
see people as having any trouble really
learning
like a new set of rules if you will i
mean i play a lot of video games or used
to when i back before we started doing
the show and i had time to play video
games but you know for example you run
into a video game where like it has a
time travel element it doesn't take long
to learn how to work in this
area where you can move in a dimension
that corresponds to to time or you learn
kind of different sets of world rules
like people somehow
don't really have
trouble necessarily but there are areas
where we're really driven
to be these radical empiricists and
certain concepts that we hold is almost
inviolable you know
like
yeah i mean but i mean this this is what
i wanted to get to as well that i mean
in walid's refutation of empiricism he
says that anything that can be
experienced or observed will be known
but we spoke with kenneth stanley and he
says well you know we experience
consciousness and we don't know it uh if
we have a hallucinogenic experience or a
dream do we know it well actually
actually
we um we reason to the best explanation
so we try and hang it on a structure
which is already in our brain so the
really interesting bit is whether we can
take percepts and whether we can build
an abstract structure and that does
largely depend on the structure we
already have but this to me makes me
think well whether it's innate already
is irrelevant because we know that we
can create new structure in response
either to thinking and reasoning or in
response to new perceptual information
of modifying these capacities what we
might do however is
games i mean at least it's in theory
imaginable
that we might discover something about
the limits of our science forming
abilities
we might discover for example that
some kinds of questions
simply fall beyond the area where we are
capable of constructing explanatory
theories and i think we even maybe now
have some glimmerings of insight into
where this delineation might be between
intelligible theories that fall within
our comprehension and
uh areas where no such theory is
possible
yeah so i i agree but i do i do think
there are limits and and i think this is
this is one of these real mysteries so
in some areas people are very flexible
and others
you know we're not and i think what was
interesting talking to chomsky was
you know when we asked um
is it possible that there are really
just these these limits to human
cognition you know this horizon beyond
which we may never go and he brought up
the example of uh
rats and prime number mazes you know
that if you have a prime number maze so
this is a maze where at every prank
intersection you take a right for
example and if you do that then you get
to the cheese or you escape the maze or
whatever the goal is
that no amount of training no amount of
time can you ever ever train a rat
to complete
a uh a prime number maze because their
brain their cognitive structure there
just doesn't have the concept
of prime numbers it it's it's just
totally lacking it's like if it was just
excised from their capability to
understand the concept of prime numbers
and he said it would be
a miracle
if we human beings don't have similar
limitations so maybe there are concepts
there that are necessary to understand
all of physics to understand the
physical universe to just they just
don't exist in any human mind and it may
even be the case that we can't even
formulate them
in any externalized intelligence form we
may just have this almost this blind
spot to this particular concept and i
think that's fascinating you know i
think there's in my mind there's really
two possibilities here one is
chomsky's correct that it would be a
miracle
and in fact there are blind spots that
human cognition doesn't have
on the other hand i think it's also
possible that there may be um
a level of of cognition
at which like let's say it's higher
order logic like once you get to the
ability to understand higher order logic
it may be it may be possible that all
facts of the universe
can be can be described and somehow and
and you know higher order logic i don't
know the answer to it but i think it's a
fascinating question
well let me push back on on that a
little bit because yeah the fascinating
thing is when you reach potentially when
you reach a threshold of intelligence
everything might be accessible because
there is this infinity of abstractions
out there in abstraction space most of
which aren't particularly useful and
most of which will always be unexplored
but with the rat example yeah they can't
reach the abstraction of a prime number
and apparently they were not trainable
but if you think about it shortcuts
exist because abstraction space is a
topological space and you could create a
breadcrumb trail and in theory you could
train the rats to learn a sequence of
mechanical steps just like a neural
network does to effectively um perform
the maze of a prime number mage without
understanding i wonder whether that's
possible
yeah i mean i think it's
i think it's always possible that in any
finite scenario
so a maze that has at most
you know
in you know intersections i think it's
always possible in any finite scenario
and we talked about this some kind of in
the context of neural networks too
sure you can you can memorize like so
i mean i don't know i haven't personally
looked at the rat you know maze
literature but but i imagine you could
probably train a rat to like
maybe always for a particular maze to
take like
the second and the third and the fifth
turn or something but
i think probably the point is that that
there's a very small number of turns at
which it it's limited like it can't go
beyond that and it can't generalize to
kind of
i say arbitrary in you know i mean
obviously uh it takes a certain amount
of time to escape and it'll die before
it can go through one million turns or
whatever that number is but but this is
the distinction that we always try to
make about
algorithms and concepts that generalize
such that
they can just be re they can they can
operate on any almost arbitrary
you know
time or number of operations as long as
you can extend
like the memory space so that the code
the algorithm is completely separate
from
from really the
the memory space if you will and so like
if i was in a prime number maze
and you just stuck me in the middle and
said hey you welcome to prime number
maze see you when you get out
well i could get out you know for a
really large number of
of turns right because i can i can count
you know three five might take me a
little while but eventually i can get
out there and and you know if you have a
machine that has an expandable memory it
could get it could continue that for an
arbitrary number of
of cycles and escape it wouldn't need to
memorize it right
that's right but then it then it comes
down to the machine of our brain or a
rat's brain and i'm interested in the
dichotomy between being able to
mechanistically perform what is an
abstraction and as you say if the
machine could take enough steps in this
abstraction space then they could
perform the prime number calculation
without understanding it and this brings
me on to godel because um walid brought
this up as well so godel's proof is all
about abstraction it's the ability to
prove a theorem finitely right so a
proof is an abstraction and you know
like wally talks about this
quantification logic right that's the
ability to use a finite object to
address an infinite set
so
um this this goedel's proof is actually
i mean waleed said it's about a space of
things that cannot be known
yeah i mean it's always it's always
treacherous territory when you when you
get into
girdles you know proof and or you know
what not because uh
um everybody thinks
everybody thinks everybody else doesn't
understand it and you know certain
philosophers think that they have the
one true
kind of understanding so i don't like i
don't want to present what i'm trying to
say here as you know
the truth like you know you guys have to
kind of decide
for yourself right but but the idea is
that in any
in any particular
finite formal system so we kind of set
down
here's the set of rules that we follow
and there's like a finite list of those
set of rules and then we start with a
set of you always got to start with
somewhere we've been talking about the
sloth conversation you start with a set
of
you know axioms or whatever so it's and
it's a closed system you know new axioms
don't enter the picture there
later on
um
there will always be statements that you
can write down in that
in that formal system that are true
they're true statements
but cannot be proved you know within
that
within that formal system so the idea is
that
you just you know you can't prove
everything either either you're
incomplete which which is what this is
meaning there are statements that are
true which i can't prove so i'm not
complete my formal system isn't
isn't complete enough to prove every
every true statement okay
or you're inconsistent
so you can
you can have a
a set of rules in which it's possible
for example to prove that a statement is
both true and false
um
but then of course you can prove that
any true statement is true
so it's you got to kind of pick your
poison here you're either incomplete or
inconsistent but it's important to keep
in mind that this applies to closed
formal systems and
technically and mathematically you know
human beings and human cognition
are not closed like this is in fact what
science does right it poses a question
okay
i don't know if this if the statement is
true or false i don't know and i can't
prove it but i can go do an experiment
and then the universe tells me like
whether or not it's true or false right
that's the fascinating thing about
human beings embedded in this universe
is that we have this process called
science which is an open-ended it's an
open system you know i want to say
open-ended because that gets us a
totally different like like question but
it's an open system that can interact
with the universe and new
stuff comes in right so we don't really
we're not strictly bound by
girdle's theorem although
any particular finite
system that we write down is but we're
always expanding that by conducting
science and doing experiment that huge
apparatus of reasoning has nothing to do
with priesthood
end of story
we don't sense
transitivity we don't say i mean that
that is a ridiculous paradigm and it has
been proven by the way skinner has been
skinned long time ago behaviorism
but at least by reputable people i mean
it's a joke you still think up uh
behaviors all i need to know i learned
in kindergarten
i i don't need to know how to ride a
bicycle that's where learning happened
i learn
you learn the skill you don't learn
knowledge
you acquire now
you just go and grab it right
i learned how to play guitars but the
universe doesn't give a damn if i play
guitars or not
because the fall
term for both is learn
right but really we don't learn that
stuff we acquire it it's knowledge
acquisition i go and i acquire i grab it
i steal
right learning is different regarding
empiricism there's this issue of what's
your unit of analysis so
are you talking about an individual
human mind because for an individual
individual human mind it's abundantly
immediately experimentally obvious
that we're not empiricists like we have
we have encoded innate knowledge for an
individual human being
but i think like fristen would expand
the level analysis to to
the species and life in general which is
that life this process of life has been
evolving you know and developing this
set of dynamics that survived
um and so whether or not you call that
empiricism
you know it's kind of a definitional
matter what i'm what i'm more concerned
about is what's the mechanism
by which by which that knowledge becomes
encoded in in the human circuitry or the
circuitry of life and
and where i what i think we're missing
or not talking about enough is that yes
observation and you know interaction
with the environment do a little bit
better than appear or whatnot definitely
plays a role but just just the mere fact
of survival
seems to play a role in imparting that
um
you know and so it'll it'll be
interesting to see how over time we
learn
more and more about how to apply
survival which we do and say ea
algorithms right like in ea algorithms
you have a population some may survive
to reproduce some don't
versus versus you know observation and
reasoning and that type of dynamic you
know learning that you do
and then the other
the other point that you brought up
there is once you have that like once
you have this knowledge
however it gets there okay so it's from
your genetic endowment it's from the
laws of nature or whatnot the human
cognitive system has learned to take
that
those seeds those seeds of knowledge and
generate with them
all kinds of mathematics like all kinds
of abstract ideas that have no
correspondence to anything that we know
of
in reality
and that's pretty much
the bootstrap
right like like
like it's it's kind of weird that there
is this platonic world of ideas
that are all you know can be consistent
and interconnected and you can say all
kinds of useful and crazy well i see
useful you can say all kinds of you know
consistent and interesting things about
them and yet they have no
there's nothing in the physical world
that corresponds to them but they're but
they're no less
you know um they're no less
sensible like they're no less
they're no less mathematical they're no
less you know they just don't have a
correspondence to reality and likewise
by the way on the other side of the coin
there's clearly a lot about the universe
that's happening
that we have no sufficient mathematics
to describe
so there's a vast
chunk maybe maybe
you know maybe the piece that's that's
even mappable to the physical world is
measure zero like in the vast chunk of
mathematics so there's this vast chunk
that doesn't map to anything in reality
and there are things happening in the
physical universe for which we have no
no mapping to mathematics for
so there are almost these these two
separate worlds that slightly overlap
here
in this little sliver
of um
of math that we would call physics right
chapter four
cognitive templates
in fact
while it's true that our genetic
program rigidly constrains us
i think the more important point
is that the existence of that rich
of that rigid constraint is what
provides the basis for our freedom and
creativity
and uh the reason why you mean it's only
because we're pre-programmed that we can
do all the things we can do exactly the
point is that if we really were plastic
organisms without an extensive
pre-programming
then the state that our mind achieves
would in fact be a reflection of the
environment which means it would be
extraordinarily impoverished
fortunately for us we're rigidly
pre-programmed with extremely rich
systems
that are part of our biological
endowment
correspondingly a small amount of real
rather degenerate experience
uh allows a kind of a great leap into a
rich
cognitive system
essentially uniform in a community and
in fact roughly uniforms which would
have developed over countless
evolutionary ages through other
basicological evolutionary processes the
basic system itself developed over long
periods of evolutionary development we
don't know how really
but for the individual it's present
as a result the individual is capable of
with a very small amount of
evidence of constructing
an extremely rich system which allows
him to
act in the free and creative fashion
which in fact is normal for humans we
can say
anything that we want over an infinite
range
uh other people will understand us
though they've heard nothing like that
before
we're able to do that precisely because
of that rigid programming but short of
that we would not be able to at all what
account are you able to give of
creativity if we are pre-programmed in
the way you say then how is creativity
and possibility for us well here i think
one has to be fairly careful
uh i think we can say a good deal about
about
the nature of the
system that is acquired the state of
knowledge that is attained
we can say a fair amount about the
biological the basis the
the basis in the initial state of the
mind for the acquisition of this system
we are only respecting the universe we
live in
it it's no more than
uh how the planets orbit each other and
they they just i mean they're obeying
the laws of physics we're we're obeying
the mental laws of the metaphysics they
call them metaphysics actually arthology
is all about metaphysics
what how the word functions
that has not been obtained
by going out
to the park
and dying three times until i discovered
that thing like that's stupid we come
equipped with that look even animals
have that by the way a calf
after two minutes
starts walking and eating on its own
if if you look at newborn and like
obviously it has to do with evolution
and how
those that didn't obey the laws of
nature didn't survive
yeah so um quite often
people confuse or conflate empiricism
with nativism so you know nativists
think that we have all of the cognitive
apparatus already built into our mind
but actually they're not synonymous i
think what chomsky says is via some
ethereal mechanism we are endowed with
the laws of nature and that's how all of
it you know
osmosis gets into our brain so you've
got a really interesting view on this
keith well yeah because i've been
thinking about this you know chomsky
said
um
look the evidence is absolutely clear
that that
humans do not start off as a blank slate
we have these endowments of of prior
knowledge one of them is obviously
genetics you know we have a genetic
endowment we have this code in our dna
that that results in structures that
unfold and grow and sure they they
develop in response to to the
environment but they're growing from
this this encoded template in our genes
but he says there's another possible
source of
of this knowledge outside of experience
which is the laws of nature
and and it's kind of a mystery how how
the laws of nature
enter into enter into our our knowledge
and
and i know chomsky would agree you know
there's some mechanism there we just
don't know what it is and i've been
thinking about that you know like what
is
what is the mechanism and
and my guess is it really comes down to
something
very
simple but profound at the same time
which is
survival okay like if you think about um
at the end of the day
life has evolved to create this
circuitry okay and it doesn't matter
whatever the circuitry is made out of
you know neurons it could be uh also in
lower you know monocellular organisms it
could be in in the in the dynamic
pathways that they're
you know the concentrations of of
electrolytes or whatever is going on
inside of them right but there's some
circuitry okay
one thing that enters into that
circuitry is does it survive to see
another day
and so
long before there were any any organisms
that did anything that we would call
observe you know to sit there and
observe nature and think about it okay
they were developing this circuitry
because as they randomly explored the
space of possible circuits
some circuits
processed information in such a way that
gave them an advantage in the real
environment i.e under the laws of nature
and they survived and ones that didn't
have processing that corresponded to the
laws of nature simply were destroyed
right and so the mere fact of survival
of existence or continuing existence
i think
encodes knowledge into
into life so it's almost a form of
ontake knowledge you know it's knowledge
that's there because of your factual
existence
and it had to correspond to some degree
to
nature and the laws of nature or you
would have perished right and i think
there's this interesting connection to
fristen's
free energy principle because it's all
about
hey look if we take the assumption
that things exist
that that definable things objects
definable things exist
and for them to continue to exist if
they continue to exist
what must they do
right that's the question he asks is
what must a definable
entity something that has this boundary
you know what he frames as a markov
boundary what must it dynamically
continue to do in order to
exist to continue existing
and and you get this free energy
principle which is that well
to you know whether you want to call it
thinking
reasoning it doesn't matter it has a
dynamics it has a dynamic behavior
that mathematically corresponds to
something like bayesian inference right
like it has to
it has to model predictions of the
future and its interaction with the
environment
in order for it to continue existing or
it would have been destroyed and so for
me this is a fascinating idea that that
you have this endowment
one comes from genetics
one comes from the evolution of life in
general which is of course encoded
genetically in us but it comes from the
evolution of life in general the fact
that it survived it's an existential
form of knowledge
but the interesting thing i mean first
of all fristen is an empiricist and it's
quite easy to look over the history of
our evolution to explain how do these
cognitive functions get implanted into
our brain and i think that that's a
that's that's a great explanation
because then using those cognitive
functions we can start to um extrapolate
into this much larger abstractive um
space but what you're saying is
interesting because there is a kind of
um epistemic resonance between the
cognitive templates we have and the
reality we live in for this precise
reason but i still think though that
it's possible for us to learn new
cognitive templates because what walid
says you'll never be surprised by
reality for that reason because the
cognitive templates that we've been
endowed by nature are the templates that
describe
the universe
yeah i agree and in this case that's
what we're saying
it it seems almost immediately obvious
that we have
we have the ability to
to learn
you know to learn or to apply definitely
to learn new cognitive templates i mean
we definitely do it you know humans are
entering
new new realms in which we didn't evolve
all the time and it's certainly
happening in the virtual space and you
know and we're certainly able to do that
the question is are there limits to that
and
yeah i mean there's obviously some very
trivial you know kinds of limits to it
but but i think there may be these
deeper limits too um it's kind of this
this question chomsky raised of
you know are we are we rats in a prime
number maze you know are we missing
certain concepts about the universe
that we just may never be able to get i
think it's an open question
um there's certainly as he puts it
there's certainly this innate drive to
be radically empiricist to try and take
our
human level understandings of you know
balls and apples and and sticks and
things like that and project it down to
to uh the level of quantum mechanics or
far out into the stars you know at the
at the like galactic super cluster level
um so we definitely have some failings
there
uh and it'll be interest you know it's
it's going to be a question that we'll
be asking probably forever uh is what
are the limits of human cognition and i
don't know
chapter five the ghost in the machine
some of you may have noticed that when
we first released this video it got
blocked by the bbc on copyright we had
included a small clip from richard
feynman from a bbc horizon interview in
1980 and back in those days the bbc
actually made quality content
remarkably
so
we also included that clip from brian
mcgee
which was in the 1970s luckily they
don't have a copyright block on that
yeah anyway let's not go there i'm
absolutely seething about it i believe
this information belongs in the public
domain i'm so annoyed with the bbc for
blocking that
anyway this is what richard feynman said
i'm just going to quote it i have a
friend who's an artist and he sometimes
has taken a view which i don't agree
with very well he'll hold up a flower
and he'll say look how beautiful it is
and i'll agree
and he says you see i as an artist can
see how beautiful this is but you as a
scientist you take this all apart and
just becomes this dull thing and i think
he's kind of nutty i mean
beauty that he sees is available to
other people and to me too i believe
and although i might not be as refined
aesthetically as he is that i can still
appreciate the beauty of a flower
at the same time i see much more about
the flower than he sees i could imagine
the cells in there the complicated
actions
which would also have a beauty
i mean it's not just the beauty of the
dimension of one centimeter there's also
the beauty at a smaller dimension the
inner structure also the processes the
fact that the colors and the flower
evolved in order to attract insects to
pollinate
it is interesting it means that the
insects can see the color it adds the
question is this aesthetic sense does it
also exist in a lower form does it why
is it aesthetic all kinds of interesting
questions which the science only adds to
the excitement a mystery in awe of a
flower
it only adds i don't understand
how it subtracts
end quote
the ghost in the machine is british
philosopher gilbert ryle's derogatory
description for renee descartes mind
body dualism now descartes as a man of
scientific genius could not but endorse
the claims of mechanics yet as a
religious and moral man he could not
accept like hobbs did the discouraging
rider to these claims namely that human
nature differs only in the degree of
complexity from clockwork
descartes and subsequent philosophers
naturally but erroneously believed that
they availed themselves of the following
escape fruit since mental words are not
to be construed as signifying the
occurrence of mechanical processes since
the mechanical laws explain movements in
space
other laws must explain some of the
non-spatial workings of the mind which
is to say the ghost in the machine i'll
talk some about uh isaac newton and his
contributions to
a study of mine that he's not known for
that but i think a case can be made that
uh
he did make substantial uh
indirect but nevertheless substantial
contributions i'd like to explain why
there is a
familiar view that
the early scientific revolution
beginning
and through the 17th century
provided humans with
limitless explanatory power
newton's greatest achievement
was that while he seemed to draw the
veil from some of the mysteries of
nature
he showed at the same time
the imperfections of the mechanical
philosophy
and thereby restored nature's ultimate
secrets to that obscurity in which they
ever did and ever will remain
the mechanical philosophy of course was
the guiding doctrine of the scientific
revolution it
held that the world is a machine
a grander version of the
kind of automata that
stimulated the imagination of the
thinkers of the time
but much in the way programmed computers
do today they were thinking of the
remarkable clocks the
artifacts constructed by skilled
artisans and there is a further task
that's to determine the scope and limits
of human understanding
incidentally some differently structured
organisms some martians say that might
regard human mysteries as simple
problems and might wonder that we can't
find the answers or even ask the right
questions
just as we wonder
about the inability of rats
just to run prime number mazes it's not
because of limits of memory or other
superficial constraints but because of
the very design of our cognitive nature
and their cognitive nature
so actually if you think it's through i
think it's quite clear that
newton's remarkable achievements
led to a significant lowering of the
expectations of science a severe
restriction on the role of
intelligibility
they furthermore
demonstrated that it's an error to
ridicule
what's called the ghost in the machine
that's what i and others were taught
at your age in the best graduate schools
harvard in my case but that's just a
mistake
newton did not exercise the ghost
rather he exercised the machine
he left the ghost completely intact
and by so doing he
inadvertently set the study of mind on a
quite a new course
this is eric curiel from harvard
university
well the world is a complex place
and our mathematical models of its parts
are almost childishly recklessly simple
how can a relation of representation
hold between them
this issue of complexity in the world is
a very serious problem
for the standard view of representation
there's um the second problem is what i
call levels of abstraction
in any given theory or or framework
within which formulates theories there
are many given levels of abstraction at
which one can write down the
mathematical formula that one
in standard parlance uses to represent
physical theories
in newtonian mechanics we have f equals
m a that's about as general abstract as
one can possibly get
does that represent in the same way as
the expression for the newtonian force
law
f equals g m m r r hat over r squared
can f equals m a represent at all
is there anything in the world that is a
pure
acceleration
even in a world in which plutonium
mechanics would be true putting aside it
is that the fact that it's not in fact
true can the latter the force the
newtonian force law the gravitational
force law can that represent in the same
way as the equation modeling two perfect
homogeneous spheres is the keplerian
binaries binary system without a
specified target
as an undergraduate when you're when
you're learning you joining
gravitational theory and you write down
the step layering binary system and
solve for it does it represent something
i have no idea
can that perfectly idealize keplerian
binary system represent in the same way
as
a set of equations modeling the earth
and sun as a concrete individual
gravitationally coupled system
with lunar and jovian perturbations
accounted for
do different levels of abstraction
represent in the same way how does one
decide when the mathematics is concrete
enough to represent
i don't know and nothing in the standard
views gives me any clue as to how to
answer that question
really the the key point that chomsky
has made a few times and he made it with
us when we were talking to him um about
what newton did you know how newton
changed
physics like forever right is is to show
us that the universe is not intelligible
to us like at least in the sense that
we can't take our kind of common sense
uh you know mechanical at the scale
which people operate where things are
have this kind of mechanical properties
right machines gears things touch each
other in order to
to have a force they have to have
contact right between objects and things
like that that there are scales or
regimes of physics where it's just it's
not the way it is like our intuition
doesn't apply to that and that was a
problem with the action at a distance
like you know gravity right you know i
mean that it's exerting this force that
behaves
as if it was pointing at the
instantaneous location of that object
and acting over
you know vast distances
instantaneously right
and it doesn't help that sure um years
later okay we we now have you know a
better theory like gr right but it
introduces all kinds of things that are
not intelligible to uh
to humans like curved space-time i mean
what's how's that correspond to anything
we perceive in reality like at our at
our level of cognition it doesn't right
and so
it's just not intelligible it's almost
you have the math
and it's almost like the the kind of
school of quantum mechanics it says just
shut up and calculate forget about
trying to
make it intelligible just just use the
tools and the math and
yeah exactly well that's why so um you
know when chomsky says that newton
exercised the machine but left the ghost
intact
he was saying that we no longer seek
mechanical explanations the machine was
exercised from our theory of science but
the ghost is still there right so after
newton the problem was largely forgotten
yeah and i think he might have made some
points about why it was forgotten i mean
i don't think it's fair to say it was
forgotten because he points out that
newton struggled with
this action at a distance you know for
the whole first whole rest of his life
right like
like really just not willing to accept
it that
that uh that there was a deep
philosophical problem there and you look
things like russell right with russell's
paradox where
where he just it just crushed his vision
of kind of mathematics even is
resting on a solid foundation but i
think it's totally fair to say the ghost
was
left yeah like we exercised the ghost
and left the or exercised the machine
and left left the ghost there i i kind
of agree with that you know there's so
much mystery left
yeah it i mean it's interesting i mean
um because now we try to build models of
natural phenomena that are intelligible
to us but you know so the model is
intelligible even if the underlying
phenomenon is not intelligible and i
guess chomsky would say that all modern
science is like that basically whether
it's quantum physics or biology or even
linguistics
and and physics so i've recently i've
been watching some interesting
um videos and lectures of uh
eric curiel from the uh the black hole
institute and he has
there there's a really cool lecture he
gave
is basically the point of it was that
mathematics does not represent and he
has some very solid arguments for how
we shouldn't even think of our
mathematics as corresponding to
what's actually happening in in physical
reality nor even that they represent
what's happening
faithfully even in that abstracted form
you know the he has a solid argument to
say look what it really is is it's a
bridge mathematics is a bridge
between
two almost equally mysterious things
one is the actual underlying physical
reality which is we've been talking
about is like not intelligible it's
weird you know it does all kinds of
things that are
not describable really or
or within the realm of our cognition and
it's a bridge between that and something
equally mysterious which are these
abstractions and concepts that somehow
exist up in our head
that we can't directly look at you know
we we perceive them and we think about
them but it's not like we can
really you know um understand where they
come from like how do we
how does abduction work right how do we
how do we come up with these
these concepts and these generalizations
and this creative act and what are they
really and there are these things that
are always almost outside the boundary
of our cognition
and mathematics is just a bridge between
those two things
um
yeah
well this is this is really fascinating
because it links back to that rat in the
maze example that that you gave because
if we shouldn't expect the study of
nature to be reducible right to to
models which are intelligible um it does
make you wonder whether it's possible at
all right to understand the world we
live in with models
why i think on the one hand an answer is
it clearly is it's clearly we're clearly
able to understand the world
to an extremely pragmatically useful
degree i mean because
we have all this technology that we've
built we've we've
you know come to understand
concepts at a scale
so small that it's it's hard to believe
anything's happening down there and so
large that
it'll forever be out of reach of
anywhere that human beings can ever can
ever get to physically right so in a
strange way our mind is able to
span and understand this vast reach of
stuff happening and yet
there's still
infinitely more
that's mysterious and and perhaps you
know forever out of reach of our
cognition and that's just
it's really fascinating to me at least
and beautiful in a way
yeah and and these are the things that
chomsky spoke about a lot in the
interview with us so there's this notion
of closedness which is that science
thrives on reductionism so by separating
one phenomenon or one effect from the
rest of the world we gain the ability to
model it to understand it and to
reinsert it into the broader picture so
you know things like physics experiments
to theoretical computer sciences
simplifications but you know this whole
thing about mechanical philosophy that
originated with galileo didn't it you
know which is this idea that we can view
the world as a machine
and galileo insisted that theories are
intelligible only if we can duplicate
you know what they do by means of
artificial devices which i think is
fascinating
yeah and and this kind of pokes a bunch
of holes in that and in in a way i'm
kind of hopeful that
it frees us up to be even more creative
with
mathematics and science and it kind of
it kind of gets at some of the aspects
that you know you and and kind of
stanley talk about
pretty often too right which is
you know we should be free right to
experiment and have serendipity and
creativity utilize those aspects of
of of human cognition when understanding
even
fundamental physics um and
you know this this analytic idea right
of kind of splitting up things and and
drilling down on the one
component that does something actually
has a lot of negative effects to say in
medicine for example like
you know we're always looking for the
single molecule that will
stave off
disease or or cure an illness right
whereas what we're trying what we're
finding out now is that sometimes you
need cocktails you need mixtures of
multiple molecules you can't just
distill it down to
the one true essence
of something you have to take a more
holistic
approach to medicine to health and maybe
even things like physics and mathematics
so i'm kind of hopeful actually that if
people accept this mortal
it'll actually expand what we're able to
understand um rather than reduce it
exactly i just wanted to to close this
bit talking about descartes as well
which is another one of chomsky's heroes
and he recognized the creative aspect of
language and thought right which is this
ability unique to humans that can't
possibly be duplicated by machines so he
said that you know language was
innovative without bounds appropriate to
the circumstances but not caused by them
and can engender thoughts in others
which they recognize that they could
have expressed themselves so and this is
actually a creative principle of the
mind he called res cogitans i remember
chomsky
arose that which stood alongside res
extensor you know which is this
cartesian dualism you know the two
substances and it's this idea that um
you know descartes actually thought that
there was a kind of separation between
our body and the um the infinite set of
expressions which could be created in
the mind
yeah and i think um was it a galileo
that he said
considered you know the alphabet is the
greatest the greatest invention was it
because it's with this finite number of
symbols
you can express this infinity of of uh
of concepts you know and
and there's so many real mysteries here
like where um the one you brought up
with what thompson called descartes
problem
you know how is it that did um
how is it that we can
have ideas and and linguistic
expressions that are not directly caused
by
by the inputs that we're getting it's
not like a an input stimulus response
right it's actually something else is
going on in there and we're generating a
new
a new linguistic expression that's maybe
never even been uttered before and yet
it somehow
maps correctly in a sense to what's
happening in the world to the to the
situation and people are able to
understand it you know and how is that
kind of
freedom of the will if you will even
possible because the best of our
our science you know points certainly at
one one interpretation of things that
it's all deterministic um even if it's
very non-linear and chaotic it's still
deterministic or if it's random it's
random in ways that certainly don't you
know provide any type of this um
freedom of will and you know he had this
this hilarious
kind of uh paraphrasing i guess of
william james where he said
you know if if you believe there's no
freedom of the will
why bother presenting an argument
you know you're being forced to do it
the person you're trying to convince
can't be convinced because they don't
have free will either so why why bother
doing it at all
i know and chomsky did say actually that
this very human ability we have to
select an action
um you know given the given the
circumstances using free will is is one
of the biggest mysteries in in science
but uh just to wrap up that i mean um
yeah so
chomsky kind of took us on an
intellectual journey which is to say
that in the olden days we used to think
of the world as a machine you know it
had a kind of mechanism and um and now
we don't think of it that way anymore
but what we do do is we construct
intelligible theories around the world
so you know we can't know what the world
is but we can build theories um that a
machine can compute so the world is not
a machine our mind is a machine
yeah i mean he said he did he did say he
said that the goal changed from from the
world being intelligible to
we'll just we'll be satisfied with
theories that are that are intelligible
i'm not quite sure if if
if he even believes that the the
theories are are always intelligible
because because sometimes
you know they're almost on the on the
boundary of of not intelligible um
but i know well um i mean remember jeff
hawkins said that um einstein's general
relativity was actually quite
intelligible because it uses a lot of
everyday concepts that humans would
understand but the thing is like
einstein didn't actually explain
um anything right all he did was he came
up with this abstraction which was a
model which was arguably intelligible
but no one really understood it
yeah and and and i think this is
something that um that i was talking
about eric curiel and that and that talk
about mathematics doesn't represent he
brings up the fact that even if you just
stick with theories okay
take something like general relativity
there are multiple
radically different formulations of
general relativity
okay like they they have very different
sort of uh
concepts atomic concepts built into the
foundation
and the you know i mentioned eric curiel
earlier because in in that talk of his
that mathematics doesn't represent
from my perspective at least he brings
up the even if you focus on the theories
just the theories themselves not the
world
there's questions as to whether those
theories are even intelligible
themselves because if you take something
like general relativity for example you
know there are radically different
formulations of it like there's the
metric formulation the tetrad
formulation there's three plus one
dimension formulation there's chiral
formulation there's four dimensional
formulations and these things have
radically different you know elements
that that make them up so even
even purely in the theory and in the
mathematics you can have very different
structures
that that all
map to the same underlying
underlying reality so how you know how
can they all be
simultaneously intelligible when they
have such radically different you know
structures
this is richard feynman again i'm
quoting
my father had taught me looking at a
bird he says do you know what that bird
is it's a brown throated thrush but in
portuguese it's a haunted
in italian it's a chute
and in chinese it's uh
he says now they know all the languages
you want to know what the name of the
bird is and when you finish with all
that he says you'll know absolutely
nothing
whatever about the bird you'll only know
about humans in different places and
what they call the bird now he says
let's look at the bird and what it is
he told me how to notice things and one
day when i was playing with what we call
an express wagon which is little wagon
which has a railing around it for
children to play with so they can pull
it around it also has a ball in it and i
remember this it had a ball in it and i
pulled the wagon and i noticed something
about the way the ball moved so i went
to my father and i said hey pop i notice
when i pull the wagon the ball rolls to
the back of the wagon it rushes to the
back of the wagon and when i'm pulling
along i suddenly stopped
the ball rose to the front of the wagon
and i said why is that
and he says nobody knows he said the
general principle is that when things
are moving they try to keep moving and
when things are standing still they tend
to keep standing still unless you push
on them really hard
and he says the tendency is called
inertia but nobody knows why that's true
now that is a deep understanding
he knew the difference between knowing
the name of something and knowing
something
feynman said something can only ever be
explained by taking something else for
granted and at some point you need to
stop this infinite regression and just
admit that you need to take something as
true on faith or simply admit that you
cannot know
chapter six
uh this is a discussion of the foda
volition
uh paper in the 1980s on connectionism
where
they put this massive critique forwards
which we think hasn't been answered yet
um and their main argument centered
around productivity and systematicity
so here's a fact
trains of thought are often like
arguments in particular they often lead
from entertaining true premises to
entertaining true conclusions
this fact engenders a problem the
problem is
suppose that the mind is a mechanism
and what after all what else could it be
since its states have causal powers
supposing it is a mechanism it would be
nice to know how a mechanism a piece of
physical matter could have this property
that minds have
how the state transitions of a mechanism
could be like arguments in the way that
the state transitions of minds are like
arguments
this is the problem that cognitive
science has made some progress on in my
view it's in fact the problem that
defines the field
turing's idea was that you can explain
the analogy between trains of thought
and argument consonant with assuming
that the mind is a mechanism if you also
assume the following two things
first that mental states are
syntactically structured and second that
the syntactic structure of a mental
state determines its causal role in
mental processes
are sometimes refer to this as the
language of thought picture of the mind
because the most obvious example of
things that have syntactic structure is
sentences
in fact it wouldn't be uh very
misleading to say that turing's idea was
that thinking is a syntactic operation
on mental sentences
and what turing argued i think
persuasively enough so that one wants to
follow out
the
research program that he set forward
what turing argued was that if you
assume that thinking is a syntactic
operation on mental sentences then the
nature of the analogy between trains of
trains of thought and arguments the
truth preserving character trains of
thought can be made compatible with the
mechanistic theory of the mind
i mean at least all the connection
inside talked about with this bite above
that as they say
no the idealization to an infinite
capacity is not allowable actually
there's only a finite number of thoughts
you could think even if you lived
forever and even if memories and
straight surreal and attention
constraints and stuff like that are are
are relaxed even under those conditions
you could be in the position of having
thought all the things you can do
and running out of thoughts
okay so that's a way of biting the book
i think
the views that the mind is is inherently
finite is a bizarre view
well i'll call a systematicity argument
the systematicity arguments are supposed
to do that they're supposed to be
arguments in the touring model that
don't require idealization the infinite
capacitance i'm going to try to set out
that class of arguments i'll argue first
that thought isn't just productive it's
also as i say systematic and that the
best explanation of systematicity
presupposes a combinatorial syntax and
semantics for mental representation just
like the best explanation with
productivity does so
um i'll argue that it can't be the case
that all mental representations are
atomic so it can't be the case that the
mind is a connectionist network that's
the form of the argument foda and
phylician wrote a seminal critique of
connectionism in the late 1980s they
released a paper called connectionism
and cognitive architecture a critical
analysis and in walid's opinion this
critique of connectionism has still been
unanswered in the paper they deride the
term sub-symbolic
it was a term that was invented in the
1980s by connectionists to
describe how a representation can be
sliced and diced and stored over many
nodes in the neural network but fodor
and violation do not think that
sub-symbolic confers the kind of
cognitive architecture which they think
is possible with the classicist
architecture
there are systematic interrelations
among the thoughts a thinker can
entertain for example if you can
entertain the thought that john loves
mary then you can also entertain the
thought that mary loves john
so systematicity looks like a crucial
property of human thought and thus
demands a principled explanation
what i have to do is to tell you what
systematism is and why it has this
implication
and here my strategy will be to start
with natural language that is i'll show
you uh what systematicity is and what
the arguments for it are in the case of
natural language and then show you why
having defined the notion for you mental
representation thought must be
systematic too okay so i'll take natural
language english and start a paradigm
case of the system which is systematic
chomsky and fodor also spoke a lot about
productivity which is basically this
idea that you can generate an infinite
number of meanings from language
in natural languages and this is just
the way making the productivity point
that i was making before in natural
languages
they're always an infinite number of
semantically distinct syntactic forms
right you can say one plus one is two
and two plus two is formed and john
believes it's raining mary said john
believes it's raining bill thought
murray said john believes it's raining
it's surprising that bill thought that
john said americans
so that's i mean natural language is
always productive in that way
jerry foda and
zenon phylician in 1988 wrote a paper
called connectionism and cognitive
architecture a critical analysis and the
funny thing was even back in 1987
these guys these classical ai guys they
thought that the hype of neural networks
and connectionism was ridiculously
getting out of control and they wrote
this paper so uh keith can you just give
us a summary of the paper
oh boy a summary of the paper first of
all the what i'll tell you about that
paper is it's it's just chock full of
goodness so i recommend um you know
anyone go and read it it's very uh
contains a huge wealth of
of thought and argumentation and
examples and
even though it was written you know back
then in 87 88 whenever it was
you'll find that it's it's as applicable
today as as it was
you know back then um
and and they come you know really the
the crux of their argument is that um
that there is
fundamental differences between
symbolic systems
and
connectionist
kind of architectures right and they try
to
they try to really drill down on what
those fundamental differences are
and the fundamental differences that
practically matter for like the
capabilities
um
of these systems okay
and really it kind of it hinges on uh
you know i guess three main
you know pillars although there's much
more in the paper than just the
discussion of this but
the one is that that uh symbolic systems
are
productive
productive systems by which they mean
you can like take like say a formula for
example
that has variables and you can
substitute in
you know structures and you can produce
you can generate you know more and more
structures from this simple set of rules
so think about like a context free
grammar for example um
you know you've got this kind of set of
rules and from that you can
generate this this infinite set of
of uh
sentences if you will that still follow
a certain structure and every single
sentence that you generate from that set
of rules
will uh will be consistent with that set
of rules it'll it'll have a certain
structure you know defined by that and
in fact you can even be given a sentence
and then parse it back to what was like
the tree that generated it and so they
had this
productive nature um and this is by the
way this is like kind of important to
understand here and we talked about this
a lot too
this is the nature of of computation is
that
it's unbounded in time so you can always
sit there and kind of
iterate and like if you think of the
turing machine you know it has like this
tape that it can go and write down some
symbols and it can go back and expand
one and expand it more and you can kind
of keep going for an unbounded amount of
time you know producing
producing a larger and larger you know
productive result if you will
everybody understands that in reality
every machine that we're going to build
is is finite
okay we get that okay but there's a big
difference between architecturally
there's a big difference between
finite state machines
and machines that have this potentially
infinite unbounded memory that they can
kind of operate on
so the idea that they're saying about
these systems are productive okay and
secondly they're also compositional
which is almost the the opposite of this
okay it's saying that
you know you maintain the parts of a
hole so even though you've you've
created a structure which is say the
sentence you still have kind of the
words in there as these separate
entities and you can go in and and pull
them apart you can analytically reach in
grab pieces of them and look at like say
a phrase that's within that sentence so
if you think about like say um
uh you know boolean satisfiability like
logical formulas you know
here's like a three sat formula a bunch
of terms and they're
anded together and then or together and
you're asking you know you're kind of
analyzing whether or not you can assign
variables to satisfy this structure like
this is very kind of nand gate type type
calculation logic you know suppose you
have a part of a of a program
that determines
for this particular task this formula
is important here like this formula
if i if i operate on all the input
variables in this way and i and i get a
value out of that okay it's it's useful
for something like determining whether
or not it's a hot dog or a human face or
whatnot and another part of the network
that figures out you know or program if
you will that figures out well there's a
different another formula that's useful
for some other task okay
in symbolic world you've actually got
the formulas
and you still have their parts and their
pieces and so you can have like a meta
analysis that takes a look at those
individual formulas and compares them
and goes oh look these two things have
the following terms in common
so now maybe those terms are important
for some purpose
whereas in a connection network you know
typically what happens and there's some
caveats here that we can talk about but
typically what happens is you've got a a
neuron a node that's performing this
calculation it collapses it all into a
single output it's like
i either fire or i don't fire with a
certain value from that point on there's
no more parts
okay like it doesn't have a part it just
has a signal 0.3
if you can't go in there and figure out
okay well that point three came from
these particular terms for this input
right there's no way to
to get that back out again it's been
convolved it's been collapsed it's been
added up and the problem is you can say
well yeah but you know some other nodes
in the neural network for example in a
connections network can have those other
terms right
but the the difficulty is then you wind
up with this exponential blow up because
how do you know in advance like which
sub terms
actually matter like okay then let's
just do all of them let's just have a
neuron for every single possible
combination of the of the um input and
it'll fire and then you know some
subsequent layer can go and decide well
i care about these these subsets that's
where you get this exponential blow up
problem from is you can't defer that you
don't have parts that you can go back
and piece apart and compare and analyze
later when you figure out there were
something you have to have baked in
ahead of time all possible
kinds of combinations
okay
has this got something to do with
intention versus extension so as i
understand
the classical ai folks they want to
maintain the intention and they don't
want to materialize the output
immediately so that in the future let's
say i've done some processing i can now
go back in time and decompose and
recompose the um the computation
yeah
i think so i mean and
i'm not sure if this is naive of me or
not i don't know but i generally think
of intention you know with the s
as uh
formulas you know they're the way i
think about them concretely is
if it's a function from all possible
worlds
to
worlds that that are true or worlds that
are possibly true worlds right so an
intention is saying look you have this
this infinite you know space of possible
worlds and a function on that that gives
you a subset
is an intention and you never actually
need to materialize it as an actual
um
you know as an actual extension that
gives you that
that set of true worlds because you have
a procedure you have an algorithm you
have a formula which can determine for
any given
you know possible world doesn't meet
that that criteria like that to me is
the difference between intention and
extension which is that the intention is
a formula that could give you that you
could iterate or apply
you know to arbitrarily many you know
worlds to generate
um to generate the extension you know of
that intention so the intention is like
the generating function right for
for a set of extension or for an
extension but
but critically the building blocks are
there so if you have the intention like
for example i use the example of the
discrete fourier transform so you can
represent represent that symbolically
and now you can change all of the
components you can change n for example
yeah because as soon as you materialize
it you don't understand it anymore and
you can't generalize it into slightly
different circumstances right yeah
exactly and this is what you know and
this is what the natural like let's say
the classic
natural language understanding folks
like wally would would talk about all
day long which is that
suppose you have a grammar okay it's
it's pretty easy to write down a grammar
you know i'm not saying it's easier to
write down grammar for natural language
i'm just saying it's easy to write down
a grammar like let's say a context free
grammar or something
and there's an infinite extension to
that that grammar there's infinitely
many you know countably infinitely many
um
sentences that that could be generated
by that grammar and it's quite easy to
build a machine that you can give it any
one of those
any one of those sentences okay
and it can churn on it for a while for
some you know
finite period of time and come back and
tell you whether or not that sentence
comes from this grammar right it can
decide whether or not that's a sentence
in this in this language
um but it doesn't need that infinite
extension existing somewhere it doesn't
have to be materialized because it just
has an algorithm it just has a simple
you know grammar that they can use to
figure that out
yeah okay okay well this makes a lot of
sense so based on reading the lacun
paper and this connectionism paper so
far
um lacoon is saying we need to have
um a probabilistic
ish
uh interpretation of possible futures
the connectionism paper is saying that
we need to have composable recomposable
decomposable abstractions right and
and this is very it's almost analogous
to what francois chile talks about with
his library of modules and and and type
2 traversal et cetera he has this
distinct dichotomy between type 1 and
type 2. so yeah it's almost as if we're
saying look neural networks at the
moment there are two
clear opportunities for improvement
and what are what are those
opportunities specifically again
so being able to represent possible
futures
with some uncertainty quantification and
secondarily being able to
i mean i'm bagging it in with the
discrete space but it doesn't
necessarily have to be discrete
functions but what we've just been
speaking about from the violation paper
composability rich abstractions
maintaining the the structure or the
intention and even later on in the
computation cycle being able to
introspect about how and why i go okay
yeah so it's the other important thing
that comes up in there in the
the pollution paper photo and promotion
paper is
is one thing that's fundamentally
different about symbolic systems is that
the code
that the the algorithm and the memory
are separated
okay and this is this is critical to
understand here which is that you have
an algorithm that can run on memory and
if it ever runs out of memory you just
need to add on another memory stick okay
and it can continue processing with the
same algorithm so the algorithm doesn't
fundamentally change if you just enlarge
enlarge the memory and this is a big
difference between connectionist systems
right because in a in a neural network
if you want to
increase the size of the input for
example like double the the vector space
or something it's all got to be
retrained okay because it's all tightly
kind of convolved together the the
memory and the computation
this is a huge difference between these
these um you know computational
paradigms so i think it's important to
understand that
it is but i guess
if i designed a system it reminds me of
object-oriented design in programming
and you create these abstractions
unfortunately they are hand crafted
although maybe it's possible that some
of them are so platonic that they would
apply in in many systems if you could
only recompose them but the
that ability to separate the storage
from the from the computation seems to
depend on that abstraction in how i
design the program and lacoone would say
well if you have to handcraft the
abstractions then learning's gone out
the window i i agree with you i agree
with both of you this is an extremely
important
problem we need to solve so once you
once you it almost once you go to the
route of saying i'm going to take my
algorithm and extract it from the memory
that's when you run into all these
training problems right because
now you're trying to train systems like
differentiable neural computers and and
whatever there are things that have
essentially
a turing machine consists of two parts
really a finite state machine and an
expandable memory okay that and then it
gets iterated and it can sit there and
keep operating on it as soon as you do
that separation and you say okay well
i'm gonna
have that finite state machine be a
neural network that i can train
differentiably the problem is now that
it's abstracted from or separated if you
will from its memory and you try to do
things like have attention and you know
be able to operate on that memory you
run into all these kinds of training
problems so it's almost like as soon as
you if you've got the memory and the
computation all
you know glued together in a single hole
that's finite you can differentiably
train it as soon as you separate it out
and make the memory expandable now you
start running into all these these
training problems but we need to do that
like we need to figure out how to train
algorithms that are abstracted or not
abstracted but separated from their
memory
and allow them to learn these
abstractions that they can then use to
operate on the memory like
somehow we have to figure out how to do
that
chapter seven we're going to discuss how
we rescued the broken recording of
jonskin
so interviewing professor chomsky was a
dream come true for us i just never
thought something like this would
actually happen
and the worst happened the unimaginable
happened the recording messed up
have a listen to this this was the
before clip there's a curious
distinction
which
and people empirically known for many
years between sentences like
one interpreter each
seems to have been assigned to the dip
the divots and this was the opticlip
there's a curious distinction
which has been empirically known for
many years
between sentences like a
one interviewer he seems to have been
assigned to the diplomats
now it would be remiss of us not to use
our combined expertise in computer
science and machine learning and whatnot
and to throw technology at the problem
essentially so the irony wasn't lost on
us that chomsky believes that deep
learning uh isn't particularly valuable
i mean i'm being a bit unfair though he
did say that it was particularly
valuable for things like speech
transcription to you know to help him
he's uh he's hearing impaired for
goodness sake but we don't take l's here
on mlst um taking l's by the way is a
british colloquialism it means that um
we do not accept uh losing so
so dramatically that's why we took it
upon ourselves to come up with a
solution you know we were not going to
let the rather minor matter of a
corrupted recording get in the way of us
realizing our dreams you know this was
the moment of our lives and we were not
going to let it slip away now we
recorded the podcast with riverside.fm
which is the podcasting platform which
is supposedly um supposed to prevent
recording problems from wrecking your
show ironically in our case it did the
precise opposite i feel at this point
like i could work as the engineering vp
at riverside or something like that
because i've got so much experience
recovering every single possible failure
mode on their platform i think i'd be
quite a useful spare pair of hands to be
around there now riverside of course
blamed it on chomsky's hardware but i
mean chomsky does so many podcast
appearances i mean he probably does more
podcast appearances than gary marcus
writes blogs trash and connectionism
when i listen back to the recording
after the show because as we were
recording the show we could hear that it
didn't sound right and we were all
saying to ourselves on on the side chat
my god please please god please make the
recording sound okay and
much to our horror it was completely
broken it was so bad i could just feel
the entire life force
of my being just draining away in that
moment i could not believe it if our
faces looked really concerned during the
interview it was because we were so
petrified about what was going to happen
when we played back the recording so how
did we fix this thing well um it's quite
a long story to be honest but even
though the recording sounded terrible
the interesting thing was that when we
ran it through a transcription service
the results were still reasonably good
so we had the word boundaries and
what we wanted to do was synthesize
chomsky saying the same thing so we
painstakingly went through the script i
mean keith must have spent about 17
hours word by word filling in the
missing gaps inferring what words that
chomsky actually said so we created a
transcript we then created a voice clone
model so we started off with a tachytron
2
voice clone which allowed us to get past
the voice authentication system on
overdub and then we recorded an overdub
voice using mostly recent clips of
chomsky but also some stuff from about
five years ago so it's probably a
the voice of a slightly younger chomsky
that you're listening to we synthesized
absolutely everything but then we've got
the lip sync problem uh the first thing
we tried doing was using lip gan and
that didn't work because chomsky has a
beard and it didn't recognize his face
so we d bearded chomsky we made chomsky
narrate the new script and
while it was a success i kind of felt it
was almost taking the piss a bit too
much it looked like a cartoon character
and we want to respect chomsky of course
as much as possible transcription for
example which i'm very happy about
because i like to use it
i like bulldozers too it's a lot easier
than cleaning the snow by hand
but it's not a contribution to science
so we decided to write a time warping
algorithm to align frame by frame the
original recording to the synthesized
version and to do that we just
transcribed the synthesized and the
original version we used dynamic time
warping so it's very similar to the
needleman-bunch algorithm in
bioinformatics so you just kind of build
an alignment matrix and then you
compute every single cell as a function
of the neighboring cells and then you
trace up behind the matrix from the
bottom right to the top left leverstein
distance uses the same algorithm so you
can kind of
keep track of matches insertions and
deletions so yeah we created the best
cost you know the minimum cost alignment
between the two tracks and then between
all of the aligned words we just did a
linear frame interpolation so when he
was saying hello in one script and hello
in another script we just did linear
frame interpolation and as you can
imagine there's all sorts of things that
can go wrong when you do that kind of
coding because there's numerical
precision problems but you know because
we were dealing with hundreds of
thousands of frames so
it was drifting over time maybe in the
future we'll make another video about
how we did that but needless to say it
was in linear time complexity just for
all of you recruiting managers at meta
i'm sure you wanted to know that
yeah so we did a pretty good job but we
wanted to stress a few things so first
of all we will make the original
recording available to peruse because i
want everyone to be completely clear
that these are chomsky's words
you can tell by the lip sync that it is
indeed chomsky's words
the amazing thing is that with the lip
sync you can actually see chomsky's
physical expression as he was saying the
word so even though technically we've
deep faked chomsky um it's amazing how
when we synchronized his expression to
the generated words it kind of just
seemed so real it was like some
invisible boundary of reality has been
transgressed again and it really was
chomsky saying all of that stuff so
there are a couple of occasions where
we've actually inserted in a little bit
of the original chomsky even though it
was corrupted just to capture him
chuckling or or you know saying some
words i mean i think there is a point
where he said language models have
achieved zero zero they've done nothing
and obviously we just wanted to capture
the original sentiment of chomsky when
he was saying those things
in certain parts the generated voice is
roughly twice the speed of chomsky
and we felt that was fair to be honest
because even if we had recorded chomsky
i might have sped it up a little bit
it's not so much that chomsky talks
slowly it's that he has gaps in his
speech i've noticed this before when
i've played clips of chomsky i've kind
of tightened up the gaps in his speech
so
if anything it'll make it easier to
listen to because there's less gaps in
his speech so i wanted to touch on
ethics because deep fakes is a huge
topic at the moment i feel that this is
a legitimate use of deep fakes we've
basically used engineering technology
which is something that chomsky talks
about in the podcast to recover a broken
interview and we got chomsky's full
permission so this is the email that we
got back from chomsky by the way this
email means so much to me personally i'm
going to frame this email i should put
this email in my cv
just doing all of this work having this
story to tell and getting this response
from chomsky to me is something that i
could tell my grandchildren about it
really is that special to me so as i
said before you can listen to the
original version just to just to kind of
satisfy yourself that we didn't put any
words in his mouth although chomsky has
checked the synthesized version and
given us his blessing
and i'll also make it clear as well that
we will be deleting the voice clone so
we're not going to use it again we're
not going to give anyone else access to
it it was just a temporary expedient and
we will now delete that
you could have said to us why didn't we
just record it again with chomsky and
the reason is just our mental states at
the time of that interview the interview
meant so much to us you can just see it
in our face it was like meeting your
childhood hero and i don't think it
would have been the same again if we
if we kind of did it again i felt that
chomsky's reactions were very novel i
felt that he said a lot of things in
this interview with us that he hasn't
said anywhere else and he really trusted
us and that means a lot to us he entered
into a confidence with us at the end of
the interview saying that um you know it
was it was a really productive
conversation and
some of the conversations he's been
having recently are quite um almost
tiring for him you know because he's
constantly having to push [ __ ] up hill
basically and we're we're his friends
you know like we we really um we're
really genuinely interested in what he
had to say and in a way we were kind of
um
i think we were really seeing chomsky at
his best and and that that is very
important and that's why i think that we
wouldn't have been able to replicate
that if we did it again but anyway um if
you do want us to go into more technical
detail about how we recover to that
recording or just in general really i
mean we are we're quite an intellectual
podcast uh by the way we've been accused
of being armchair philosophers there's
lots of gatekeeping apparently uh going
on on the ml reddit but yeah it's quite
a funny story as well that we had baited
breath right so we had spent about a
month fixing this recording um it was
quite stressful for us because we've got
a huge backlog um you know it took quite
a while to get the code running we
weren't working on the intro just
everything was just getting out of
control keith and i had a massive
argument about it and
all of this time i think we were
stressed that it would be for nothing
because we had asked chomsky for his
permission to publish it and then he'd
say no anyway and it'd be like all of
that time was wasted so um you know it
was a really tricky situation for us
because we felt cornered we felt like
there was no other option this was the
only thing that we could have done so um
yeah it was it was quite an interesting
story to tell at the end of it
chapter eight
language
people like for example wilhelm von
humboldt and rousseau they both grasp
the idea that languages are basically
infinite that they're expressions of
human creativity in fact that's a
leading cartesian idea at some core
level
part of human nature which is reflected
on the cognitive side in things like
language is the capacity to produce and
understand and articulate and express
new thoughts without limit
and without control so the crucial
fact about language use is that it's not
determined by our situation it's coming
out of us as
freely willed action in some sense and
continually novel and so on and to
express thoughts and ideas that are new
to oneself and other people but that are
intelligible and appropriate and so on
this
is a core aspect of human nature chomsky
is a big believer in autonomy free will
creativity and novelty shouldn't be
entirely surprising given that he's an
anarcho-syndicalist it's really
important for him that we are individual
actors that have free will that is not
determined by the situation we're in
which is why he quite often says that
language use is appropriate to the
situation but not caused by the
situation
but the really interesting thing that he
says about language is that it's an
expression of human creativity language
is an infinite space of possible
expression which is what makes it so
remarkable what is language and is there
even such a thing
as a pure language english is relatively
homogeneous you can go a long way in the
united states you know i mean i just
came from boston and i understand
everybody in portland and seattle and so
on but that's not true most of the world
you can get very different languages
pretty close by
and much of the world is what we would
call multilingual but what does it mean
for the language to be pure or when
people say they want english to be pure
what are they talking about was
shakespeare pure i mean
first of all there is no such thing as a
language there are just lots of
different ways of speaking that
different people have which are more or
less similar to one another some of them
may have prestige associated with them
for example some of them may be the
the speech of a conquering group or a
wealthy group or a
priestly cast or one thing or another
and we may decide okay those are the uh
the good ones and some other ones the
bad one but if
if social and political relations
reversed we'd make the opposite
conclusions chomsky is often referred to
as the father of modern linguistics
so for us having this rare opportunity
to discuss
minds and machines linguistics and
cognition with professor noam chomsky is
literally like having the chance to
discuss syllogisms
with socrates or having the chance to
discuss the mind-body dualism with renee
descartes it really is that fascinating
and it really did happen professor
chomsky was so humble as to give us some
of his precious time to discuss many
contemporary issues especially as they
relate to many hot topics in artificial
intelligence chomsky's goal as a
linguist is to find principles that are
common to all languages which allow
people to creatively speak freely and
understand each other
chomsky's work is so much more than
linguistics he actually thinks that
linguistics should be a branch of
psychology and that so much about our
language actually determines how we
behave as human beings
i think finding the principles common to
all languages and understanding what
enables us to speak freely and
importantly creatively
is noam chomsky's number one goal in
life as a linguist
chomsky said that when we study human
language we're approaching what some
might call the essence of humanity the
human essence the distinctive qualities
of mind that are so far as we know
unique to humankind
hey folks i really hope you enjoy the
show with noam chomsky today i mean as
you can tell from the introduction this
has been an emotional rollercoaster for
us just over the last couple of months
or so we've done so much stuff to
recover the recording to build the intro
it's a slightly new domain for us as
well getting into cognitive psychology
but anyway please hit the like and
subscribe button drop us a comment let
us know what you think we've got six
incredible shows coming up we're
building introductions for them as we
speak uh you know the likes of joshua
bach and uh david haar and and many
others i don't want to spoil the
surprise so yeah hit the subscribe
button and i really hope you enjoy the
show today
cheers
chapter 9 the chapter that you've been
waiting for this is our discussion with
chomsky
enjoy professor chomsky is an american
linguist professor
cognitive scientist social critic and
political activist sometimes called the
father of modern linguistics and is the
most cited living academic he's a
laureate professor of linguistics at the
university of arizona and an institute
professor emeritus at mit
some of the big names which professor
chomsky has influenced include stephen
pinker jerry foda george lakov and
barbara party
professor chomsky it's an absolute honor
to welcome you to mlst this is a dream
come true for us i've still got 10 of
your books on my bookshelf and i can't
even believe we have this honor of
speaking with you today
very pleased to be with you
large language models such as gpt-3 are
receiving huge investment and are being
hyped beyond belief this is happening
despite very strong theoretical
arguments for the futility of learning
language from data alone
the combinatorial complexity of language
is on a scale which would eclipse any
earthly data set
there's also this problem of the
so-called missing text that is to say
human cognition extrapolates from common
knowledge in order to understand text we
can ascertain background knowledge which
is never actually communicated in the
text we believe that research into large
language models is what francois chorley
recently called make believe ai and is
thus the road to nowhere
gary marcus even calls it apollo trick
assuming that you do
believe that large language models are
not the solution for natural language
understanding which paradigm do you
think is the most promising well first
we should ask the question whether large
language models have achieved anything
anything in this domain answer no
they've achieved zero so to talk about
the failures that's beside the point let
me give you an analogy
suppose that i submitted an article to a
physics journal saying
i've got a fantastic new theory and
accommodates all the laws of nature the
ones that are known the ones that have
yet to have been discovered
and it's such an elegant theory that i
can say it in two words
anything goes
okay
that includes all the laws of nature the
ones we know the ones we do not know yet
everything
what's the problem
the problem is they're not going to
accept the paper because when you have a
theory
there are two kinds of questions you
have to ask
why are things this way
why are things not that way
if you don't get the second question
you've done nothing
tpt3 has done
nothing
with a supercomputer it can look at 45
terabytes of data and find some
superficial regularities which then it
can imitate and it can do the same with
all languages
if i make up a language which violates
every principle of language with 45
terabytes of data
the same super computer and will do the
same thing
in fact it's exactly like a physics
paper that says anything goes so there's
no point in looking at its deficiencies
because it does nothing
oh it doesn't waste a lot of energy in
california i should be more careful it
has some engineering and applications
that can be used to improve
live transcription for example which i'm
very happy about because i like to use
it
i like bulldozers too it's a lot easier
than cleaning the snow by hand
but it's not a contribution to science
so it's okay i mean if you want to use
up all the energy in california to
improve live transcription
well okay
gpt-4 is coming along which is supposed
to have a trillion parameters it will be
exactly the same
it'll use even more energy and achieve
exactly nothing for the same reasons so
there's nothing to discuss it's exciting
for the reporters in the new york times
you probably saw the lead article in the
times magazine a couple of weeks ago
they're absolutely ecstatic we now have
machines just like a human you can fool
reporters but you shouldn't be able to
full computer scientists yeah first of
all i can't say how much of an honor
this is professor i mean
um
it goes without saying that uh
we think uh you're
one of the
people that know something about
language unlike
what we hear these days
uh so
as you can imagine there are many
questions that i can ask but i'm gonna
ask a question that
is uh is about the current dominant
paradigm
uh i'd like to know your thoughts on the
current
rise of connectionism or
connectionism or the resurgence of
connectionism let's put it that way
and the ostensible success of deep
learning
and specifically i'd like to know
do you think the classic photo and
piloting
critique
that was written in the classic paper
connectionism in cognitive architecture
a critical analysis do you think
the critique there has been answered
or do you think the success of deep
learning
has been
illusory
well i think there's a good answer to
this question and an interesting
research paper by a very good cognitive
scientist at northeastern university
iris baron she did a study which
essentially shows that in brief and
persons of his innate she found that
with studying children adults and so on
they're automatically driven radical
empiricist conclusions it's just
something that comes naturally to us
okay that's connectionism no matter how
much it's refuted it's all going to come
back because it's an instinct our
instinct is to try to find something
like that it's kind of like what
happened in the 17th century the problem
in the seventh century was the nature of
moshi that was called the hard problem
in those days how can you account for
the fact that without contact you can
make things move and there was already a
mechanical science developed by the
court and i believe galileo newton and
everyone actually newton in his
principia showed that it doesn't work
there were no machines nothing works
like the machine does it's an invention
but it's not real it was very hard to
deal with
newton himself regarded the conclusion
as a total absurdity and spent the rest
of his life trying to refute it latents
christian hygienes the great scientists
of the day they just assist this is
ridiculous and there's a reason the
mechanical science is intuitive that's
what we think about things study infants
uh put two bars near each other but not
touching and if they move together the
infant will assume there's a connection
that's the way we're built
it took a long time for physics to
realize the world doesn't work that way
the way we intuitively think about
things is just not the way the world is
maybe someday cognitive science will
reach the level of physics and 19th
century and recognize that our intuitive
concept of the world isn't the way it
works so the photo position critiques to
the point was accurate but
it barely touches the surface
the whole approach is radically wrong
everything we know about learning
totally refutes it and what we call
learning is mostly the kind of growth
it's the growth of natural instincts in
one or another way under the triggering
slightly shaping of experience the
entire framework of these things is
wrong and you can see it very clearly in
the case of use of language it's very
easy to show by now it's even been
experimentally demonstrated that
from infancy
as early as you can contests less than
two years old children are ignoring 100
of evidence that they're presented
within relying totally on mental
constructions that they never perceive i
mean i can give you examples but it's we
all do it all the time in our use of
language we simply ignore all the data
and use mental constructions and infants
do it as soon as they test it
it's not learning this is just
instinctive behavior that's the way our
visual system develops it's the way you
come to walk the way your immune system
develops and language develops and other
things
other aspects of knowledge in fact there
are many things we know about language
that we don't even know that we know we
can't introspect into them you have to
have to do experimental work to show
that people know them but just i mean
that's just like other aspects of the
organism i don't expect to be able to
introspect into the functioning of your
entire nervous system the so-called
second brain the huge nervous system
very much like this one which is just
down here and runs most of your body not
an enormous nervous system that has
billions of neurons which you can
introspect into but
why should you able to introspect into
what's going on in the year it can't you
have to study it from there on the
outside the way you study everything
else
well that's hard philosophers won't
accept it at all they totally reject it
just like they rejected newton as
obviously absurd but the cognitive
scientists occasionally look at it but
don't really think about it the rest
just aren't interested i mean we're back
in the 16th century in these fields and
we have to break out of that that's not
easy it took a long time for physics to
break out of it in fact pat newton's
theories couldn't be taught at his own
university cambridge for about 50 years
after his death
because they were so obviously absurd
well
if it's hard for physics it's going to
be harder for cognitive scientists as a
quick follow-up uh
connectionism symbolic
[Music]
that that debate has went on for a long
time do you think there's any
any credibility to what people call
hybrid or uh
neurosymbolic and it goes under
different labels
do you think there's anything
to that
approach at least okay learning
everything from data probably is
is
in in some people's mind not
practical but is there anything
that
neurosymbolic approaches or hybrid
approaches can can
uh
can deliver to
the whole debate
yeah there's a lot of extremely
intelligent exciting work it's not it's
not trivial work you know there was a
lot of thought and understanding
mathematical sophistication and so on in
this work
it just doesn't happen to be
contributing to science
it's contributing to other things like
deep learning approaches have been very
useful in
protein folding for example they've
really advanced understanding there it's
a good engineering technique that is
i mean i'm not a critical of engineering
i spent most of my life at at the
world's leading engineering institute
mit it's terrific you know i mean it's
useful for things like the google
translate
uh live transcription speech recognition
there are engineering projects that are
significantly advanced by these methods
and that's all to the good i think that
engineering is not a trivial field it
takes
intelligence
invention creativity these great
achievements
does it contribute to science i actually
i think there was an interesting
transition at mit
where i was most all my life in the
1950s when i got there
that was the time when i was beginning
marvin minsky herb simon other people
alan turing who were in their view
it was supposed to be a study of the
nature of intelligence
it was a scientific field
by now that's disappeared not anybody's
interested but at mit at that time was
an engineering school there were great
people in math and physics but they were
basically teachers and engineers
though it changed in about 10 years by
the mid-1960s 10 years later
mit was a science university
engineering was unified every student no
matter what engineering discipline they
want to go into took the same
fundamental courses
in science and math you take basic
physics basic chemistry biology math and
then later on you apply it in aerobical
engineering or mechanical engineering
whatever you're interested in that was a
huge transition totally changed the
nature of the institution
they brought humanities in for the first
time because the science students were
interested in humanity
and what really happened was that that
for the first time the basic sciences
had something to teach to engineers
that hadn't happened before if in the
1950s you wanted to build a bridge or
construct a lecture theater or something
you just did it by
skills that had been developed in the
engineering profession
well in the 1960s that was no longer the
case physics and math really had
something to tell you
so you had to know something in order to
move ahead
well that took a long time you know
that's physics after it was a developed
field were a long way away from that in
the cognitive sciences
but unfortunately that kind of work that
people like herb simon and marvin manxy
were interested in
has pretty much disappeared from ai it's
become basically an engineering field
though it has plenty of achievements as
i say
engineering is a very noble profession
uh just doesn't contribute to science
professor chomsky other than the issues
with large language models we discussed
there is also the let's say
minor matter that we're not silicon
our biological wetware implements a kind
of hybrid analog and digital computation
which might
might realize aspects that are
effectively impossible to replicate
in digital circuits alone
sir roger penrose goes as far as to
hypothesize that our brains take
advantage of
quantum properties to access
non-computable oracles
making our brains what turing would have
called oracle machines
we'd like to ask where you stand on
these points perhaps you are a
computationalist who believes human
cognition can be digitally replicated in
silico
or maybe you are open to the possibility
that human brains are hyper computers of
some kind so what do you think
well first of all i'm completely
incompetent to have any opinion about
roger penrose's theories about quantum
properties
you know i have no idea he's a smart guy
obviously he's a
you have to pay attention but i frankly
don't think it matters
not at this stage of understanding
at this stage of understanding i don't
see any reason
to question the fact that we are
organic creatures like the rest of
nature
that
whatever's going on here is some
property of organic matter whatever
matter is and then if it could be
duplicated in a silicon system
it essentially wouldn't tell us anything
it would tell us there's some general
properties of this organic system which
also exist in some other system
maybe but since we don't know what's
going on up here i don't see a lot of
point in speculating about it but the
very basic questions to deal with
about the nature of what we know about
authentic language
our ability to deal with what you and i
are doing here
there are fundamental questions about
that that unless we have some grasp of
those
i really don't see a lot of point in
speculating about quantum theoretic
properties or
possible silicon duplicates of what we
don't understand here
so yeah they're possible questions they
just don't seem to be at least to me
on the research agenda
now penrose of course seems to be
thinking about a serious problem a
problem about memory
memory models that are studied are
mostly in the neural net models
and in fact deep learning is based on
those
there is a serious question about
whether neural net models are even in
the right place to look
it's uh i think here randy galisto's
work is very significant
arguing that
if you look at neural net models
they simply don't have to have the
capacity
to have the basic elements of a turing
machine
the core
of computing is going to be some form of
turing machine
that he's argued i think pretty
persuasively you simply can't find those
elements in neural net models
no matter how you proliferate them uh
penrose has recently picked up the same
idea
he's argued that
as gala still has that
computing is not being is not taking
place in neural net models that there's
a lot more reasons to think so
rather it's at a much deeper level you
know maybe even an rna if you look deep
inside the cell there's huge computing
capacity it goes way beyond what you can
achieve in neural nets
it also isn't in trouble there's a big
problem with neural nets that goes back
to helmholtz they're damn slow
neural transmission is slow of course
not by our standards but by the
standards of anything you need for
computing by the uh and if you go back
if you go down to
i mean they've known there already is
work showing then that perkins sales
have huge computing capacity internally
just their big very big cells internally
without any external connections
and maybe that's the source of uh
where compute is really going on in the
brain i think that's the kind of thing
that penrose is doing he argues that at
that level you do have quantum effects
well maybe so um i can't make any
judgment about that but there's a large
problem not being
that that's biting this this work the
question of whether the whole framework
of neural net models is even appropriate
uh the way the way galistol puts it are
we like the drunk living under the wrong
lamppost you know
cause that's where the light is
you believe that there are limits of
human understanding uh mysteries of
nature which human intelligence may
never grasp and cannot formalize
professor kenneth stanley goes further
and claims that the veneer of formalism
in particular the formalism of metrics
and objectives may paradoxically impede
scientific progress by blinding us to
creativity and serendipity in
exploration and learning he believes
that open-ended exploration something
which he calls treasure hunting is
necessary to find valuable stepping
stones which might lead to greatness
that is to say stepping stones which
formal objectives would have blocked us
from discovering i just wondered what do
you think of this view
well first are there questions that can
be formulated that are outside of our
cognitive range i think it would be a
miracle if it's not true unless we're
angels
that's going to be true if we are
organic creatures
part of the organic world then there'll
be scope and limits to our capacities in
fact the scope and limits are related
so i have the capacity to walk much
faster than a chimpanzee much better
than an eagle
but by the same token
i can't fly or jump around trees
the same intrinsic characteristics that
provide me with capacities impose limits
but well that's almost a bit of logic
not exactly but it's pretty close
so if we are organic creatures we're
going to be like other organic creatures
and that there are bounds to our
cognitive capacities so for example a
rack can be trained to run pretty
complicated nases but it can't be
trained to learn a prime number maze
turn right at every prime number it just
doesn't have the concept
and no matter how much training you do
you're not going to get anywhere
well i suspect there's reasons to
suppose we're like rats we have
capacities we have a nature we have a
structure that yield all sorts of
extensive range of things that we can do
but they probably impose limits
and i think we could even make some
guess about what these limits are
actually one of them was suggested
pretty strongly in the 17th century
i mean we're not any smarter than newton
galileo leibniz
nothing relevant has been learned to
help alleviate her concerns and i think
we have the same concerns
to me it's as much of an absurdity as it
was to newton though i can move the moon
by raising my hand total absurdity okay
they didn't regarded it as an absurdity
lavender did galileo did they wanted an
explanation
in terms of an intelligible universe
that was the goal of early modern
science
let's find an intelligible universe and
an intelligible universe meant
mechanical science something that
skilled artisans could construct
like incredible clocks other
objects that skilled artisans were
constructing in europe at the time
which almost acted like humans
so that's the way the world is
directed by a super skilled artisan if
you were a dazed then went home
it was a retired engineer who set it up
and then left it run by itself was the
big issue at the time but the point is
the universe ought to be intangible
making sure that the universe is not
intelligible and what happened after
newton took a long time science just
reduced its aspirations
it doesn't seek to find an intelligible
universe
it just seeks to find intelligible
theories about the universe
so leidnitz could understand newton's
theories they were not intelligible it
was the world that we were describing
that was unintelligible
well that's a big shift in the nature of
science it wasn't particularly
recognized but it just became tacit
you don't even even look for
intelligibility anymore
you want theory that meets the
conditions of intelligibility for a
theory for example we get to what we
started with the theory is no good at
all unless it tells you why things are
not this way
okay otherwise it's not a theory in the
least
like gpt3 deep learning and their
approaches they don't under the domain
of
theories you can even look at it
so there's nothing to say about them
but like my anything goes theory but um
that's a condition that theories have to
me but what the world is mean we have
nothing to say about it
whatever crazy things physicists come up
with okay if that's the way it is that's
the way it is
you know it's not intelligible to bad
for my cognitive capacities
well what are the mysteries in this
universe that are beyond our scope i
think we can make some guesses there are
questions that have been asked for
thousands of years where we have made
zero progress
not even bad ideas about them
one of them is the 17th century hard
problem motion
we've given up on that
motion is whatever physicists tell us
if it's gravitons in a quantum system
okay then that's what it is
beyond our capacity to i don't conceive
of except we understand the theory uh
so i think that's one candidate another
candidate is what you and i are now
doing that's been a problem for
thousands of years have who would be
constructing in our minds
infinitely many thoughts
picking out of them
how do we do that and then communicating
it in a way which allows others who have
no access to our thoughts
to grasp what's internal to our minds
how on earth do we do this
galileo regarded this as one of the
great miracles of the universe and is
totally beyond our understanding
galileo regarded the alphabet as the
most spectacular of human inventions
because it somehow captured this miracle
with a finite number of symbols
you can not only construct an infinite
number of thoughts which is miraculous
enough but you can also pick one of them
out
and use it to convey to the others the
internal workings of your mind
we have absolutely no idea not even bad
ideas about how any of this can go on
in fact we don't even have any idea of
how i can decide to lift my little
finger none
it's just a total mystery uh of course
you can make claims about it but you
can't do anything about it well maybe
it's just beyond their cognitive
capacities
and i think there are examples like that
where we just hit a blank wall we can't
do anything
whether there's further things to say
about it
i mean even ordinary normal creativity
the kind that goes on like in speaking
normal speaking is a highly creative act
a scientific invention is a greater
creative act great art is an even
greater act but but all those things
are totally beyond our comprehension
from lifting my little finger
to writing a beethoven quartet we
haven't a clue
or talking we just have nothing else to
say about it
fascinating it's a cognitive horizon
this is regarding the the many theories
of semantics that have cropped up over
the years
for example truth conditional semantics
logical semantics ontological semantics
etc
which if any paradigms of semantics do
you think are headed in the right
direction
as far as getting us closer to an actual
science
of semantics
or will we ever have a formal science of
semantics as montague thought
well i think there's very rich exciting
work in what's called semantics
it's been one of the most lively fields
of theory in linguistics
philosophy cognitive science and years
you mentioned barbara purdy earlier one
of the pioneers in this field great work
it's not semantics it's syntactics it's
all study of symbolic manipulations that
go on in the mind
suppose you do model theoretic semantics
the kind barber party does how you do
model theoretic semantics
what you do is identify certain
individuals
and certain predicates and you ask how
the predicates are distributed over the
individuals
under various conditions what are the
individuals
mental objects not things in the world
they are mental objects or something
do they correspond to anything in the
world
very loosely
if you actually look carefully at the
mix of words
uh there's a very loose connection to
anything in the outside world
take aristotle's example
he discusses this uh his example is
house
so what's a house
well in his metaphysics
house is a combination of form and
matter
the matter of a house is the bricks the
timber things that a physicist could
find
the form of the house is the intention
of the designer
the characteristic use
things that are in the mind
in fact that's what a house is
the thing could look exactly like a
house for a physicist
and not be a house
it could be a library
it could be a stable could be a
paperweight for a giant you know
it could be anything
because the meaning of every word is
largely a matter of our conceptual
structures
and that's true the simplest words that
you find
actually the first example that was used
in physical philosophy was river
pericle is pre-socratic as
having you cross the same river twice
it's a pretty deep question if you think
about it the second time it crosses its
totally different physical object
it wasn't the same river when you start
looking at that
the form it's what we construct in our
minds as what constitutes river
but i happen to live in arizona now
on my way to the university i crossed
something called the relito river i have
yet to see a drop of water uh old-timers
tell me
if you could go with them on soon
there's sort of water flowing
though it's a relato river um if it got
paved over and started to be used for
commuting
it would be the reliedo highway
it's the same object
uh and that's true for every word in the
language
there is simply no semantics and natural
language at least semantics of the dense
of fridge tarsky
corner coin any formal semantics
it just doesn't exist in language
we have mental operations going on that
have some loose relation to the outside
world but it's not
truth
and it's not reference
there's just no occurred
so
what's the best approach to this
my own view
the most productive approaches are they
what are called the event semantics near
the davidsonian developed by paul
pietrowski
barry shane a number of others which
essentially
started with a question like uh why
can't if we say
john read the book quickly
why can we infer that john read the book
okay that was the original question and
the proposed answer is there's an event
reading uh
there's an agent john there's an agent
book and there's an adverb the modifier
of the event quickly if you analyze it
that way
that's just the concatenation
and you get the inferences
that's been developed extensively by
people like piotrovsky and shane among
others
that happens to fit very naturally too
what is
i think is
a coming we're coming to understand is
pierce index
it seems that that's the way
pure syntax provides structures of that
nature which fits very naturally into
events and semantics
but notice the event somatics is syntax
when you talk about an event
it's not anything in the world it's
something that we constructed our minds
uh there was a gentleman named zeno
who taught us something about that
how many events are there when i cross a
room
as many as you decide to put there
you know there's no end up to the power
of the continuum
the so uh event somatics i think is
productive as a form of syntax
then comes another question
how do all these things going on in our
mind
relate to the outside world
that's one of those questions that don't
think we have any answer to
now we're back to galileo's problem
how we do these things
we don't know we do them we do a lot of
things but uh we have no understanding
we'll probably never have an
understanding of it
i i'd like to ask you professor about uh
what what do you think is the
relationship between
what you have called uh
universal grammar or the i language and
folder's language of thought which
uh
has been also
quite uh
a theory in linguistics and cognitive
science
and if we can suppose that both as human
innate systems
endowed by genetics and or the laws of
nature
if that is a similarity
or is it and if not uh
or and if it is
how do they differ like a bit so
basically how are they similar
and how are they different
uh that gets to the heart of current
advanced inquiry in my opinion
stewart
uh jerry fodor was a close personal
friend
we talked about these things all the
time but ask yourself
what's the language of thought
far as i know it's english
uh do you know anything about the
language of thought that isn't english
not in jerry fodor's work
just english well of course it's not
english
but it should be what is common to human
languages
whatever is common to human languages
that should be the language of thought
though what's common to human languages
universal grammar it's just its
definition
that's the name of what is the core of
all languages
whatever it turns out to be
asking what is universal grammar is
asking what are the laws of nature
well
try to find them you know but make the
best cases
you know
find out they're wrong
find better ones and so on that's
universal
but there is debate in the cognitive
science of the virtue about whether
universal grammar exists
it's another illustration of the
pre-scientific character of cognitive
science
the question is meaningless
there's something that distinguishes a
human infant from a chimpanzee with
regard to language okay
if you don't agree with that
you're a flat earther but if you agree
with it the next question is what is it
answer universal grammar whatever the
turns out to be
the question about its existence doesn't
even arise i mean it's like arguing with
somebody who says everything's done by
angels
useless discussion you know so the
question is what is it that's
distinctive about human language
that it's important um there is a long
tradition going back to aristotle in
fact
rife for centuries into the 20th century
assumed that what a language is is a
system for generating thought that
language was sometimes defined as
audible thought
you know we know audible is too narrow
now we know it can be signed in other
sensory motor systems
it's irrelevant
it's like a computer program that can be
hooked up to any printer
it doesn't care
but that's the internal thing like the
computer program or the i language
that's a system of thought and the
language of thought will be
whatever that system happens to on a
compute
probably identical among humans far as
we know there's no distinction among
humans at least the capacity to acquire
a language any infant
as far as we know can acquire any
language with equal facility
so it's probably uniform which would not
be very surprising but humans are a very
recent species
couple hundred thousand years
that's a flick of an eye in evolutionary
time
and we know from genomic evidence that
humans began to separate on the order of
150 000 years ago
that means there's a very narrow
and they all share the language faculty
equally and there's no new evidence that
existed at all before modern homo
sapiens so there's a very narrow window
in which it seems to have emerged
probably hasn't changed since
so we have certain expectations
it should be something very simple
something that you just followed from
natural law
if you look at the way evolution works
uh
not stories
actual evolution basically has three
sages
the first stages you have system
function some random disruption takes
place
really random annotation a gene transfer
some bacterium by accident swallows
another microorganism
gives you variety
eukaryotic cells
complex life you know just random events
take place and they change the structure
of the system and mother nature comes
along at this stage and finds the
simplest solution to
whatever development what einstein once
called the magical cree
latency's law of least effort it always
seems to work
in every branch of science whenever you
understand that anything
turns out it was the simplest solution
so that's the way mother nature works
can't really give an explanation but
it's so overwhelmingly supported that
nobody even questions it and if you
don't have the simplest solution you
figure you're wrong you know
that's the ordinary scientific way and
as i say
einstein just called it the magical
creed that's the way it is
that's how nature is
so we'd expect that
when mother nature some event took place
random event which provided homo sapiens
with the capacity for recursive
enumeration
the fundamental property of the
computational system
no other organism has it
it's nowhere you know it's uniform in
humans
mother nature came along and said okay
let's find the simplest way of handling
recursive illumination with some special
conditions
namely it has to produce thought
so it has to have some kind of at least
primitive way of having conceptual
entities which enter into the thought
light probably event semantics like
maybe we can save the world in terms of
events
agents uh
patience uh modifications so on put that
together with recursive enumeration
find the simplest possible solution that
ought to be a universal group
to the tests of researchers in
linguistics and cognitive science ought
to be see if you can ensure that the
simplest possible solution to this
conundrum uh yield explanation for the
phenomenon of language that's the task
of the field
almost nobody's interested in it you can
count the number of people on the
fingers of one hand but that's what the
field ought to be
and i think they're progressing in that
i think we're maybe entering a new era
where for the first time first time ever
we can give genuine explanations for
fundamental properties of language
in fact one of them i mentioned the most
striking dramatic feature of languages
what's called structure dependence the
fact that from infancy every human
understands unconsciously that all the
rules of language while operations and
language have to ignore their order of
words and deal just with structures
so ignore everything you've heard deal
with the abstract structures in your
mind you can demonstrate this directly
overwhelmingly
that's the way it works we now have an
explanation for it
turns out that that's what follows from
the simplest combinatorial operation
the simplest combinatorial operation
happens to be binary set formation
what's called merge and contemporary
literature
well if language is based on binary set
formation you get this property
no linear religious structures
so we had a
for the first time ever a deep
explanation for the most fundamental
property of language which is a very
surprising property which tells you
something about learning cognition
and so on almost nobody's interested in
it they take a look at the literature
and cognitive science there's an endless
number of papers trying to show that by
massive statistical analysis of huge
amounts of data
you can begin to approximate but you can
explain nothing i mean of course they
all failed
it's not interesting why try it in the
first they have a perfect explanation
the best possible for some fundamental
mental property what's the point of
trying to see if a couple of
supercomputers and massive amounts dated
they can approximate it i mean it's
madness you know
but that's the field that we're in it's
madness that's it and you can't it's
very hard to get this across
i mean
it's not of interest to people
the idea of finding an explanation for
something it's just not of interest i
mean it was for touring was for more of
minsky
who i know pretty well herb simon the
other pioneers of mccarthy pioneers of
ai you know that was interesting to them
they tried well
it wasn't me at that time and it was
given up
and i'm busy know the field by now
that's considered old-fashioned nonsense
we don't care about that stuff anymore
it's uh in other words we don't care of
anything of any interest
we just want little things that make
some money okay
that's okay that's what you're
that's probably where the field will
develop that's where the money is
you know and the jobs but it's a sham i
think some people try to hang on to the
old ideas since they want to do
something of intellectual interest
which profound misunderstandings of
language and linguistics persist even at
the highest levels of the scientific
community do you mind that many of your
own scientific ideas are widely
misunderstood
totally misunderstood it's amazing to me
so there's one paper of mine
that i presume you know about
it was in 1956 at three models for the
description of language that did into
the literature
i've been very interested in the fact
that for 60 years the paper has been
totally misunderstood and no matter how
many times i try to explain it i can't
make any progress
uh you've probably you probably haven't
looked at that paper but you get the
material drawn from it in elementary
introductions to cognitive science
what's called the chomsky hierarchy
which is all stuff i said you shouldn't
be looking at
that's what the paper said
the paper had three models
one of them was markovian sources
everybody was using at the time and
argued it can't work
the second model was rewriting systems
poster writing systems
which if you put some conditions on you
get context sensitive context free
grammars finite automata so the
hierarchy there was a third novel
that's why it's called three models
the third model was the only one i
thought made any sense
because it began to provide some
explanations for things the other ones
were just descriptive models wrong
descriptive models
but the only thing that's come out of
that paper is the role models there's
huge literature on context free grammar
context sensitive grammar i've written
about it it raises some interesting
questions about automata theory
that you know
context-free grammars happen to be
broadly equivalent to push-down storage
automata
kind of a useful result but basically
they tell you nothing about language
these models models just deploy the
language they're the only ones that have
been studied and in all literature in
the last 60 years nobody's noticed
there's a third model
though the paper is called three models
and the point of the paper is to show
that the other models just don't work
well that's only 60 years
maybe somebody will notice but the but
the more interesting question was the
first part
what are the misunderstandings
and i think we can a useful way to look
at is to think of what have been major
problems
they've actually been given names
so let's use the name
uh the plato problem how can we know so
much with so little evidence
well that problem is badly misunderstood
and there's
uh we started off by tovi about one of
the misunderstandings
the idea that if you have enough data
you know trillions and trillions amount
of it and you have battery of
supercomputers working you're going to
deal with this problem
no you're not you're going to get
nowhere
you can show in advance that you're
gonna get nowhere
okay that's one misinterpretation
which holds not just for computer
science it holds for philosophy
linguistics total misunderstanding
i think probably for our experiential
reasons were instinctively radical and
persist
and it's hard to get out of that it
took the 17th and 18th century for
physics to break out of it
another problem is what's sometimes
called darwin's problem how do we get
this language system
uh it's inning it's common to humans
no variation as far as we know
no trace of it in any other organism
there's a lot of time wasted trying to
train poor chimpanzees to duplicate some
of these things which makes about as
much sense as trying to train graduate
students to do the waggle waggles of the
bees
when you could train them to somehow
mimic it maybe but it would be idiotic
it's equally idiotic to try to train a
chimpanzee to do what we're doing
well
for the first one the graduate students
you can't get an nsf gram for that
because it's so obviously idiotic the
second one which is equally idiotic you
can get grants for a lot of people
working on it and so on
that's part of the overwhelming
irrationality of the way the human mind
is studied
that's darwin's problem
now the last problem is what's now
called descartes problem how can we do
what we're doing right now
how can we speak in ways which are
appropriate to situations
but not caused by them
that's a huge problem
which is basically the question of
freedom of choice how can we do it years
a this is we're involved in it all our
lives but it's very interesting if you
look at the philosophical literature the
scientific literature is sort of
interesting but virtually percent of
people who think about saying we're all
determined we're all thermostats
everything we do is totally determined
you look at the behavior of the same
people a hundred percent of the time
they act as if they're not determined
so and it's this way constantly then
even the people who give arguments
saying determined or testedly assuming
we're not determined
otherwise do i give the argument
um you know if it's determined if it's a
thermostat why bother so that goes all
the way up to einstein and gave
arguments trying to show that
everything's determined proving by his
effort to do it that he was not
determined okay so here we have a kind
of a paradox
everybody says we're automated everybody
acts all the time as if we're not
automatic will the science say anything
about this nothing
science says we can't deal with it it
says we can deal with it with
determinism
we can deal with randomness
but we can't deal with things that are
not determined or random so here's the
system situation
some extraterrestrial intelligence is
looking at us
these strange beasts down here
a hundred percent of the time it says is
determined a hundred percent of the time
it acts as if it's not determined it
believes science which tells it nothing
all right is it a misunderstanding
sure seems to me like a deep one so if
you go to plato's problem
darwin's problem
descartes problem you see very profound
misunderstandings which dominate the
fields all the fields philosophy which
is supposed to be sophisticated is
probably the worst of all
maybe i can add one point about
confusion
if you look at the philosophical
literature today
there's something that everyone's
obsessed with
it's called the hard problem
the problem is consciousness what's it
like to see the sun rise
let's go back to the 17th century
which is an interesting century it's the
birth of modern science they had a hard
prob problem as it was called
the emotion the hard problem was motion
uh how was a hard problem dealt with in
the 17th century well properties of
motion were formulated
they said here are some properties of
emotion
you know galileo's experiments and so on
actually thought experiments he never
carried them out if he tried to carry
them out it never would have worked they
were thought experiments you know
you drop a
dropper ball from the top of the mass of
a moving sailboat and it falls to the
base
not to the back thought experiment
if he tried he would have got craziness
but uh that there were properties of
motion that were established and then
came the hard problem
how can we explain the properties of
motion
well the answer was we can't so we give
it up we move to something else trying
to do theories of the properties of
motion without understanding the
properties
that's the 17th century
now let's go to the 20th and 21st
century
there's something thing called the hard
problem
what's it like to see the sun rise
there's a step missing the step that was
taken in the 17th century
what are the properties of being of it's
being like to see the sunrise
i can't tell you i could write a story
about it write a poem about it but i
can't say here are the properties of
what's like to see the sun rise so
what's being posed is an unanswerable
question
a question that can't be answered
so if you pose an unanswerable question
you're not going to get an answer
the question can be answered only if you
can formulate it
that you can say here's what i'm trying
to explain
but you got this huge literature
total obsession in philosophy of mind
how can we answer an unanswerable
question
i mean one philosopher a young
philosopher
galen strawson commented the 20th
century must be the silliest century in
the history of philosophy he's
exaggerating but not by too much in a
we're in a strange period in all of
these fields
we're just consumed with elementary
misunderstandings
it's very hard to break out of them
it's a very irrational period
it's reminiscent of the period when
people argue about the right
interpretation of the eucharist and so
on
you know i mean it's a strange period a
lot of sophistication but massive
misunderstanding
i'm curious um on the on the side of say
things that we might be able to answer
what do you think some of the greatest
remaining mysteries of language
science or philosophy
which we have yet to solve and yet may
be able to answer
and which are some of the areas of
research that you find most personally
exciting exciting to those ends well i
think there are questions right at the
border of research
which i think are very exciting like the
one i mentioned
i mentioned that i think for the first
time ever
for thousands of years we can now give
deep explanations of some fundamental
properties of language and foot which
are probably the same thing let's assume
that language and thought are two
different ways of looking at the same
thing thoughts what is generated by
language and language is what generates
thought
and one of the deepest mysteries is this
property of structure dependence that i
mentioned
in fact it's the deepest property and a
very surprising one and we now have a
perfect answer to it it's accounted for
by the simplest but the assumption that
nature acts the way nature always acts
by finding the simplest solution
then the simplest solution for a
combinatorial system happens to be
binary set formation well you look a
little further there's much more to it
but that's the beginning of it and now i
think we can press forward with that as
what what should be a component of
language
assuming that nature is perfect
but you look you find there are some
things which are there only because they
follow from these properties
so uh there's a subpart language called
control theory
uh you have a curious
uh now i have to get into details but
there's a curious distinction
which has been empirically known for
many years
between sentences like a
one interviewery seems to have been
assigned to the diplomats
one interpreter each tried to be
assigned to the diplomats
first one's okay second one isn't uh
why
well
the answer is a whole system called
control theory and we now have an
explanation for it in terms of the
assumption that nature picked the
simplest possible answer
that kind of question that can now be
raised for the first time and sometimes
answered
well i think that's exciting moment in
history of the study of mine that i see
it interact with what to me at least
seems the most promising mode of formal
semantics namely event semantics that
links very closely to that so if you can
work out the ton of remaining detail
it's not elementary you can imagine how
you'd work them out you would have a
basic answer to the structure and
understanding of our system of thought
and expression
that would be a pretty exciting
development i think there's many others
so for example you know this goes way
beyond my competence so i can just talk
about the problems not what they mean
but
somebody
a friend
a quantum physicist recently sent me a
paper in a quantum theory journal which
was a symposium of half a dozen leading
figures in quantum physics they were
discussing what is a particle
they have no idea
they don't know what a particle is
it's a big thing you have to talk about
in physics
they have a lot of vague ideas about it
but they don't know the answer well that
sounds like an interesting question to
me what is a particle and here we go
back to the question of consciousness
and look at the strange way the topic
isn't studied you go back to newton
again let's say
newton recognized that we know so little
about matter that we cannot say that all
matter has life
maybe a stone we know so little about
matter so little about life we can't say
with our own matter as life well back
last century sir arthur eddington great
astrophysicist he said we know little
about matter we can't say whether all
matter is conscious not because we don't
know about consciousness we know massive
amount of consciousness more than
anything else
but we know nothing about matter
so we can't say whether all matters
conscious
well that's question two i don't think a
stone is conscious
but can i surely know enough about
matter to explain that a stone isn't
conscious
that's a lack of knowledge about matter
so we not me but advanced physics will
pursue the question can we find out
enough about matter to answer questions
like this or even tell us what a
particle is well those are questions at
the border of research and in every area
you're in you have the questions what's
life you know
versus non-life uh any area of science
here in you overwhelmed by questions
like these
some of them are at the border of
research so you can hope to go forward
others are so beyond far beyond that you
can't even speculate sensibly about them
some of them may turn out to be true
mysteries for humans that it's just
beyond the cognitive capacities you have
to study them in independent ways you
know kind of sideways
well among the problems of language era
what the neural bases
what's the neural basis for language i
mean something's going on in our brains
when we're doing this
what's going on it's very hard to find
out partly for ethical reasons you just
can't do the experiments that might give
you some
answers because they were unethical you
can't stick an electorate into a
particular neuron and broke his area to
find out what's going on we do it with
cats and monkeys we don't do with humans
oh well you could argue about cats and
monkeys
but
the fact is we do it that's the way
we've learned about the visual system
but you can't with the language system
there's no organism that has anything
like it so you can't do it with other
organisms
we don't allow it to do it
we don't allow ourselves to do it with
humans
we don't raise humans in controlled
environments to see what will happen or
in principle
if if the nazis had won the war maybe
we'd be doing it but we don't do it so
it's just very hard to find answers
to questions that even when we know how
to find the answer that means you have
to be much more ingenious do much more
sophisticated experiments
but these are things at the borderline
of inquiry actually yesterday i sat in
the dissertation defense of somebody
who's actually working on this
there were interesting things uh white
white matter connections between brookes
and warnick's area
two areas that seem to be implicated in
language and
there's some evidence that these way
matter connections become super
myelinated in early development in
humans but not apes connecting the two
uh um areas of the brain that seem to be
implicated in language and interestingly
they also have a connection to the
auditory system also lacking in apes so
maybe
there's something in white matter that
has something special to do with
language that's the kind of topic you
can investigate from the outside in any
area of science you know about you got
many questions like this so there's no
shortage of things to study it's just a
shame that
huge amount of effort money scarce
energy or wasted in doing things that
make absolutely no sense
well and professor chomsky we're gonna
wrap the conversation here but can i
just thank you so much for coming on our
podcast it means so much to us
sincerely thank you very much pleasure
to talk to you what was the best thing
about talking with chomsky
best thing about talking with chowski oh
boy um
i think i'll tell you what and this is
kind of personal to me i think because
you probably know and from the show and
whatnot you know i i like plain language
i mean sometimes i'm forced to use
technical terms but i like
plain language and i like to think about
concrete things and i like to make jokes
about you know bulldozers or you know
very down-to-earth
kinds of topics right and so when i
realized how
down-to-earth he is and and and somebody
that you could just hang out with and
joke joke about and talk about
things concretely in the real world and
yet he's
you know the foremost
intellectual of our
era right i think um it was nice it was
nice to see that like you can be both at
the same time you know you can be you
can be
an ordinary
human being
and an extraordinary intellectual
all rolled into one yeah
he was taking the piss out of neural
networks he said he liked bulldozers too
yeah they weren't a contribution to
science yeah exactly well exactly so you
know he's saying they're a great feat of
engineering they just don't they don't
contribute to science and i just i just
i found it really enjoyable to talk to
him was it was very um
it's very fun he's very funny and
and uh yeah just all around it was it
was great great experience
yeah and officially this has been
in terms of production and the amount of
hours of faffing around this has been by
far by far the longest cycle we've had
on any episode
yeah and of course i've already made
some content about how we fixed it but
yeah it's just i mean we've fallen out
over it
we've made up again now
but yeah it's been an incredible slog
just getting it all fixed and thank god
chomsky let us publish it yeah you know
as we've explained here or elsewhere in
the show i mean it was obviously a lot
of it was accidental okay we didn't you
know technological failure that resulted
in this challenge but i have to say
for me personally uh it it made the
journey all the more epic and satisfying
that we um that we really pulled off
this
um
you know chomsky called himself a
miracle of engineering you know to to
restore the show it doesn't contribute
to science but it was a uh
was a miracle of engineering and i mean
you know it's it's it's one of these
life stories that i think um in the end
i'm going to remember forever and it
couldn't have happened
i mean in a way
the the uh the person that we were
interviewing this was
the perfect person for it to happen to
other than
than the loss of quality quality because
of just all the ironies and sort of the
the process of doing it and and you know
we we really wouldn't have put this
tremendous amount of effort into it for
for anyone else so
unfortunately we ran out of time the
production cycle has been so long but
there were a few moments in the
recording with us where chomsky was
chuckling and it meant so much to us to
kind of capture that mental state so we
didn't have time to cut them back into
the synthesized version but here are a
few clips of chomsky chuckling in
response to us
well that sounds lounge literacy
question to me
what is a particle
maybe somebody will notice
but the
seems seems to me like a deep woman she
never carried them out the ton of
remaining details it's not